COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD AFTERNOON. IN RESPONSE TO
THE KOBE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT ON NONESSENTIAL GOES HERE
TO FLOW FROM THE SCENE. AND FACE
COVERING- GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE THESE THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS IN THE SWING SPACE-
CLEARLY. I. S. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO BE A PRESENT IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SO WE
CAN ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM
BEGINNER HEARING- I KNOW SENATOR
ALSO IS- PRESIDING OFFICERS WILL
BE HERE. MOMENTARILY DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR. LEANED UP WITNESSES WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES FOR EACH
WITNESS AND THERE'S NO RESERVING
TIME FOR OTHER WITNESSES. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURES. FOR THESE
pOF TEN MINUTES FOR SUPPORT IN
TEN MINUTES PROPOSITION FOR EACH
PRESENTATION FOR EACH BILL. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS ACCESS
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. IT WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX. EIGHT ONE SIX THREE.
AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT ONE SIX THREE
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN SIX
TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO. SO SIX TWO
TWO FOUR SIX TWO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS. PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE OR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION. THIS
IS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN SOMETIMES BE A SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOU MY NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE ON MUTE. AND YOU'RE THEN
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT. TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. PLEASE MUTE THE DEVICE
YOU WERE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU. WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING THIS IS CUSTOMARY. IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE
TO BE REMOVED. FROM THE REMOTE
MEANING SERVICE FOR HEATHER
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE HAVE
ELEVEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA-
BEFORE YOUR PRESENTATION ON
THOSE BILLS WITH THAT WAS A
QUORUM- CONSULTANT ASK YOU TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
PURCHASING YOUR COURTESY HERE
ARE TWELVE OAK. THE RUSSELL.
THERE BLAIR HERE NEWMAN YOUR NO
MAN HERE WE HAVE A CORE CONSOLE
NOTES SO THE QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED TO KNOW WHEN WE HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR SAWSAN
EARLY THE COMMAND WELCOME- AND
IF YOU'RE READY YOU MAY PRESENT
YOUR BILL SB NINE THIRTY ONE. TH
TH. YOU GUYS HEAR ME NOW WE CAN
SEE THAT THAT HELP TO TURN MY
COAT EVERYTHING IS VERY LOW FOR
THOSE OF US THAT ARE TALL. SO
GOOD AFTERNOON I AM HAPPY TO BE
HERE TO PRESENT S. B. NINE
THIRTY ONE- WHEN I WAS ELECTED
EIGHT YEARS AGO I WAS TOLD DON'T
FALL IN LOVE WITH YOUR BILLS.
BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU I AM IN
LOVE WITH THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
A GREAT BILL. SB NINE THIRTY ONE
IMPOSES PENALTIES ON PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS FOR UNLAWFULLY
ATTEMPTING TO DETER OR
DISCOURAGE EMPLOYEES. FROM
JOINING OR PARTICIPATING IN A
UNION. WE AS A LEGISLATURE HAVE
ALREADY MADE CLEAR THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS ARE PROHIBITED FROM
DETERRING UNION MEMBERSHIP BY
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. AND APPLICANTS
FOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT. AND
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS
ARE AUTHORIZED TO BRING UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICE CHARGES YOU WELL
PEAS. AT THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS BOARD HERB FOR EXACTLY
THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR.
UNFORTUNATELY IN VIOLATION OF
THE LAW SOME PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
HAVE REPEATEDLY SENT OUT ANTI
UNION COMMUNICATIONS. TO
EXISTING BARGAINING UNITS OR
WORKERS ATTEMPTING TO
COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN. BUT AN
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION SUCCEEDS
IN PETITIONING PERK TO GRANT AN
UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE CHARGE HER
CAN ONLY ISSUE A CEASE AND
DESIST ORDER. REQUIRING THE
EMPLOYER TO POST NOTICE OF THE
VIOLATION. BY THE TIME OF THE
NOTICE THE DAMAGE HAS ALREADY
BEEN DONE. IT IS OBVIOUS THAT
SOME PUBLIC EMPLOYERS ARE
DETERRED UNDETERRED FROM
BREAKING THE LAW AND WILL
CONTINUE TO VIOLATE THEIR
EMPLOYEES RIGHT TO ORGANIZE
UNLESS THE LEGISLATURE ACTS TO
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL CONSEQUENCES.
S. B. NINE THIRTY ONE WILL
IMPOSE A ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR
PENALTY PER VIOLATION PER
AFFECTED EMPLOYEE NOT TO EXCEED
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. BY
CREATING A FINANCIAL PENALTY
PENALTY FOR VIOLATING SECTION
THREE FIVE FIVE ZERO OF THE
GOVERNMENT CODE EMPLOYERS WILL
HOPEFULLY THINK CAREFULLY BEFORE
INTENTIONALLY DISCOURAGING UNION
ACTIVITY IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR.
WITH ME TODAY TOO SURE EXACTLY
WHY THIS BILL IS NEEDED OUR MAP
ROAD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL
AND CHRISTOPHER MAHER WITH ASKED
ME. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. VOTE- THANK YOU SENATOR I
WILL TURN TO LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESS. NUMBER ONE MAP ROAD IF
YOU'RE PREPARED TO MAKE A LIST
OF THEM HERE ARE YOU HEAR ME
ALRIGHT YES ALL RIGHT MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MATT BROUGHT HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COUNCIL. WE'RE AT PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB NINE THIRTY ONE
WHICH AS SENATOR LEYVA SAID
CREATES ROBUST PENALTIES FOR
VIOLATIONS OF GOV CODE THIRTY
FIVE FIFTY. WHICH PREVENTS
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYERS FROM
DETERRING OR DISCOURAGING UNION
ORGANIZING ACTIVITY. THE
LEGISLATURE SPOKE LOUDLY AND
DECISIVELY FOLLOWING THE TWENTY
NINETEEN U. S. SUPREME COURT
DECISION AND JANICE WHEN HE
DECLARED THE POLICY OF
CALIFORNIA IS THE NECESSITATE.
LABOR NEUTRALITY ON THE PART OF
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS UNFORTUNATELY
CINCINNATI WHEN A SECTION THIRTY
FIVE FIFTY WE'VE SEEN CERTAIN
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS REPEATEDLY
BREAK THE LAW WITH LITTLE TO NO
RECOURSE. IN FACT JUST LAST WEEK
PROVING ENDED DOWN A DECISION IN
FAVOR OF THE TEAMSTERS WITH
RESPECT AT THIRTY FIVE FIFTY
VIOLATION AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. DURING AN ORGANIZING
CAMPAIGN THE DISK AND CAME CLOSE
TO THREE YEARS AFTER THE
COMMUNICATION AND THE ONLY
REMEDY WAS FOR THE EMPLOYER TO
POST A CEASE AND DESIST NOTICE.
ALL THOSE TAKE YEARS TO LITIGATE
WAS EXTREMELY COSTLY TO THE
UNION THE DAMAGE WAS DONE THE
MINUTE THE COMMUNICATION TOOK
PLACE. S. B. NINE THIRTY ONE
WILL GO A LONG WAY TOWARDS
REMEDYING THIS WHOLE AN EXISTING
LAW. BY CREATING A SUBSTANTIAL
PENALTY RECOVERABLE DIPPER
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS WILL THINK
TWICE BEFORE MAKING BUSTING A
CON A CONSCIOUS PART OF THEIR
LABOR RELATIONS STRATEGY AND OF
COURSE THERE IS ZERO PENALTY FOR
COMPLYING WITH EXISTING LAW.
WITH THAT I WOULD URGE. YOUR
EYES THAT NIKKI FOR THE
CONSIDERATION. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER. NEXT TO. IN SUPPORT.
CHRISTOPHER MAHER GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KRISTOFF MEYER AND I AM HERE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES WE LINE OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF MR BRAUN
ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS
ASSAMESE HAD SIMILAR EXPERIENCES
WITH EMPLOYERS WHO HAVE
REPEATEDLY INTERFERED WITH
ORGANIZING EFFORTS AND REMAINED
UNDETERRED BY THESE CONSEQUENCES
. THESE EMPLOYERS CONSIDER IT A
WIN TO DISRUPT THE ATTEMPTS TO
UNIONIZE EVEN IF THE EMPLOYER
HAS TO SPEND TIME AND RESOURCES
DISPUTING A VIOLATION OF SECTION
THIRTY FIVE FIFTY. JUST LAST
MONTH MANAGERIAL STAFF AT UCSF
TOLD NEW EMPLOYEES OUT RIGHT
THAT THEY SHOULD NOT JOIN THE
UNION BECAUSE THE MANAGER SAID
THE UNION WOULD TAKE THE
EMPLOYEES MONEY AND NOT DO
ANYTHING TO HELP THEM. PLEASE
JOIN US IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
IMPORTANT ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURE
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
MOORE IN TO APOLOGIZE TO BOTH
LEAD. SUPPORT WITNESSES FOR-
INNER IMPROPERLY PRONOUNCING
YOUR NAME SO GIVE THAT RIGHT THE
NEXT TIME I SEE IT- WE ARE GOING
TO NOW ASK THERE'S ANYBODY IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS A SUPPORT POSITION WE'RE
DEALING WITH SUPPORT RIGHT NOW
WE'LL DEAL WITH OPPOSITION IN
FEW MINUTES. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS THE SUPPORT POSITION
Q. PLEASE COME FORWARD- IN YOUR-
ALLOWED TO STATE YOUR POSITION
IN YOUR AFFILIATION YOUR NAME
YOUR FILIATION OF COURSE.
TEMPERAMENT IN ASHINGTON OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS AND FULL
SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU. KAREN MEMBER SALLY
HANDLED ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA WERE PROUD CO
SPONSORS AND WE HAVE OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS WE HAVE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. HELLO
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JANICE MALLEY
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION- WE
ARE PRO CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE
HERE WISHING TO EXPRESS THE
SUPPORT POSITION LET'S SEE NONE
WILL MOVE TO THE- MODERATOR NOW
IN ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY. ON
THE PHONE LINE WHO WISHES TO- TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF THANK YOU
MR CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN FAVOR OF S. B. NINE THIRTY
ONE THEY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IF YOU WERE IN QUEUE
FOR ANOTHER VIEW OF ANOTHER
BILL. YOU MAY REMOVE YOURSELF BY
PRESSING ONE AND THEN ZERO AGAIN
. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
THIRTY ONE THE PRESS ONE AND
THEN. ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
LOOK UP THERE WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SHEET METAL AIR RAIL AND
TRANSPORTATION WORKERS-
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION MARTINI
AND PULLED PORK. RIGHT HANDER
INTEGRATED. NINE TEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
SOUTH BRAMBLE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE PROCESSING OUR
SUPPORT POSITION. NINE THIRTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS PAT BROWN
WAS THERE IN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL SITE
SINCE THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEER IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT OWNS OR
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION SIDE OF
THE EQUATION AND LEAD
OPPOSITION- IS MICHAEL BOUCHARD
FROM UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. IS
THIS MICHAEL OR MISTER BUT OUR
NATION SAFE HERE WITH US OR ON
ON THE PHONE YEAH. I'M HERE ON
THE PHONE GREAT WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU. THANK
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS%
MICHAEL BUT ARE HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO SEND A
COMBINED THIRTY ONE UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED. YOU SEE HAS REQUESTED
AMENDMENTS TO AWARD ATTORNEYS
FEES TO EITHER PREVAILING PARTY.
AND ALSO AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
THAT THE COUNTIES IN THE BILL ON
THE FLY THE PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
MASS COMMUNICATIONS AS DEFINED.
IN GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION THREE
FIVE FIVE THREE. MASS
COMMUNICATIONS INCLUDE ANY KIND
OF WRITTEN VERBAL RECORDED OR
OTHER MESSAGE INTENDED FOR
EMPLOYEES- FULL FULL OF FLEAS.
HELLO REQUIRES PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
LIKE TO SEE MEET AND CONFER
PRIOR TO SENDING OUT THOSE
MESSAGES. IF PARTIES CANNOT
AGREE ON THE CONTENT THE
EMPLOYER MUST BE REQUIRED TO
INCLUDE A MESSAGE FROM THE UNION
AT THE SAME TIME IN THE SAME WAY
. I UNDERSTAND THAT- BUILDINGS
ON A RECENT ALLEGATIONS OF THE
DETERRENT DISCOURAGE CODE
SECTION HAVE THUS FAR ONLY
CONSIDER THE FACT MANY CASES
THAT TRUST ME I WOULD ALWAYS BE
SO. AND SENATE BILL NINE THIRTY
ONE WOULD ADD A NEW PENALTY
AUTHORITY THAT NEEDS TO BE
CLARIFIED. WITHOUT VERIFICATION
AS POSSIBLE EVERY U. LP FILED
WILL INCLUDE AN ALLEGATION THAT
THE UNDERLYING CLAIM ITSELF WAS
DETERRING OR DISCOURAGING. IT'S
pNOT UNREASONABLE TO IMAGINE THAT
EVERY CONTRACT DISPUTE OR
BARGAINING IMPASSE WOULD BRING
OUT WAR P. POTENTIALLY SUBJECT
TO PENALTIES. THERE IS A NATURAL
TENSION BETWEEN LABOR AND
MANAGEMENT BUT NOT EVERY
DISAGREEMENT. SHOULD RESULT IN
PENALTIES. PENALTIES THAT TAKE
PUBLIC FUNDS INTENDED TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF. AND
THEN GIVE THEM TO A DIFFERENT
PUBLIC EMPLOYER WITH A DIFFERENT
PURPOSE. THESE REASONS YOU SEE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE SENATE
BILL NINE THIRTY ONE UNLESS IT
IS AMENDED. MORE CLEARLY DEFINED
WHAT CONSTITUTES A DETERRING OR
DISCOURAGING UNION MEMBERSHIP.
THANK YOU AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE ON THAT
UNTIL NINE THIRTY. THANK YOU MR
DARDEN WILL NOW COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM AND ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE. PRESENT IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS AN OPPOSITION POSITION.
THE SP NINE THIRTY ONE. SEE NO
ONE COME FORWARD WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR S. MODERATOR TO
PLEASE. QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
EXPRESS OUR POSITION AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE THIRTY ONE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AND IT'S FINE. NINE
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RUNNING VERTICALLY
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION. WE SHARE THE
OPPOSING LESS AMENDED POSITION
AND ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU MODERATOR WILL BRING UP
BRING IT BACK WITH THE COMMITTEE
FOR DISCUSSION OF ANY MEMBERS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME YES- VICE CHAIR HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THE OTHER.
THREE LEAVE A- WELL FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. I DO HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR AND- NUMBER ONE. USUALLY
WE PROVIDE A CHANCE FOR AN
ENTITY TO CURE- A MISTAKE BEFORE
WE IMPOSE FINES AND PENALTIES.
MADOC ADVOCATE FOR THAT BUT IN
THIS CASE IT DOESN'T SEEM THAT
THERE IS ANY CHANCE FOR PUBLIC-
FOR THAT PUBLIC EMPLOYEES TO FIX
A PROBLEM BEFORE- IT IS AN ISSUE
WOULD YOU BE OPPOSED TO
INCLUDING LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
REQUIRE. THE UNION MUST MEET AND
CONFER BEFORE FILING THIS CHARGE
WILL PROVIDE DISCRETION TO
PERMIT SO THAT THEY CAN ISSUE A
WARNING. THERE'S NOT ALWAYS A
RIGHT HERE- AND IN THIS CASE IF
THERE WAS A RIGHT TO CURE THE
DAMAGE WOULD ALREADY HAVE BEEN
DONE. BECAUSE ONCE A AN EMPLOYER
HAS BEEN FOUND GUILTY OF- DO YOU
ANTI UNION- RHETORIC OR ANTI
UNION- SPEECH OR PAPERWORK OR
POSTINGS OR MEETINGS WITH TEIR
EMPLOYEES RIGHT NOW WITH THE
CURRENT LAW SAYS IS THAT THEY
JUST HAVE TO POST INTO A CEASE
AND DESIST. MANY TIMES IT CAN
TAKE SEVERAL MONTHS BEFORE THAT
SEASON THIS IS THE MAIN PURPOSE
EVEN PUT UP AND THE PROBLEM IS
THE DAMAGE IS DONE WHAT WE WANT
TO DO IS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S A PENALTY. SO THAT
EMPLOYERS DON'T EVEN THINK ABOUT
INFRINGING ON WORKERS RIGHT TO
FORM A UNION UP WORKERS FEDERAL
RIGHT TO FORM. SO WOULD YOU MIND
EDUCATING ME BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW THE PROCESS OF WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN SOMEBODY ACTUALLY DOES
SOMETHING OF THIS SORT WHICH IS
THE CURRENT PROCESS ON THAT AND-
IT GOES TO PERM. AND THEN
PERMANENT A RULING OR FINDINGS
AND THEN IF THEY ARE FOUND THE
EMPLOYER IS FOUND TO HAVE BEEN
<c.cyan>UILTY. OF ANTI UNION ACTIVITIES</c>
THEN THEY POST A CEASE AND
DESIST USUALLY IN THE EMPLOYEE
BREAK ROOM BUT THAT CAN TAKE
MANY MANY MONTHS AND LIKE I SAID
BEFORE THE DAMAGE HAS ALREADY
BEEN DONE. THE EMPLOYEE HE HAS
ALREADY HEARD ALL OF THE
RHETORIC AND ALL OF THE ANTI
UNIONS FEEL SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS PUT IN A PENALTY TO
KEEP EMPLOYERS FROM DOING THAT.
OKAY AND THEN NUMBER TWO I ALSO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH HOW THESE
SIGNIFICANT FINES MAY AFFECT THE
SOLVENCY OF OUR OF THE EMPLOYERS
WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO REQUIRING
THAT PERSON THROUGH AN
EMPLOYER'S ABILITY TO PAY- AND
THE SIZE OF THEIR GENERAL FUND
BEFORE SIGNING A PENALTY NO IT
IS REALLY QUITE SIMPLE AND
QUITE- QUITE IT'S JUST REALLY
EASY DON'T ENGAGE IN THE
ACTIVITY AND THEN YOU WON'T HAVE
TO PAY THE FINE. THANK YOU
WELCOME. OKAY THANK YOU BYE SURE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM FROM OTHER MEMBERS PRESENT
ON SCENE NONE- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE I'M SORRY YES THAT'S
RIGHT A NEW PASSPORT FIRST
REFERRED THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY ON THE US. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I MOVED.
RACHAEL VERY CLOSE YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST THANK
YOU ALL FOR THE OPPOSITE AND I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU ALL BUT
IT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT OR NEW
ROOM HERE SO WE'RE ALL GETTING
OUR SEA LEGS OF IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THE BILL AS SOMEONE WHO
WORKED IN THE LABOR MOVEMENT FOR
TWENTY YEARS WE THOUGHT
EMPLOYERS DO THIS WITH SOME
PLAYERS SPEND MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON ANTI
UNION CONSULTANTS OR WHAT THEY
COULD HAVE JUST DONE IS TAKING
CARE OF THEIR EMPLOYEES.
EMPLOYEES HAVE THE FEDERAL RIGHT
TO FORM A UNION EMPLOYERS DO NOT
HAVE THE INHERENT RIGHT TO
DISCOURAGE AN EMPLOYEE FROM
JOINING A UNION THIS BILL WILL
HOPEFULLY DISCOURAGE EMPLOYERS
FROM DOING THE WRONG THING AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
UNDER IS NOT ONE OF THE MOTION
BY SENATOR NEWMAN AND NOW US-
THE CONSULTANT TO CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. COURTESY
ALL RIGHT. COURTESY I OR TO
EVOKE. A TROUBLED NOW THE
RUSSELL. LAYERED HI THERE I
NEWMAN. NEWMAN I THANK YOU MR
CHAIR THANK MEMBERS. OKAY SO
WE'LL WE'LL PUT THE BILL ON COLD
CURRENTLY WITH A THREE TO ONE
VOTE ON THE RECORD MISTER CHAIR
YES SO YOU WERE HOME WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS ON CONSENT ITEMS THREE AND
ITEM SEVEN I KNOW MR ARCHULETA
HAS ONE AND HE'S HERE SO I WOULD
MOVE TO CONSENT ITEMS WAS GOING
TO HOLD OFF UNTIL SENATOR ROSE
WHO GOT HERE BUT WE CAN GO HERE
HALF THE REST OF ROLE FOR HER
FOR THE OTHER STUFF ANYMORE.
THAT IS TRUE HAPPY TO DO IT.
THAT'S A- THE PLEASURE OF THE
COMMITTEE- SO ON THE CONSENT.
IDMS WHICH WOULD INCLUDE- SP
EIGHT FIFTY AND S. B. NINE
EIGHTY FOUR- WE HAVE A MOTION AS
ANDERSON FROM CENTRAL AIRED. AND
CONSOLE SHOULD PUSH OVER. WHERE
SHE IS RIGHT ON CUE OCEANA
READERS PAUSE FOR A MOMENT
PLEASE- A CONSULTANT AND WHAT
SENATOR ALSO GET SITUATED SO WE
DON'T HAVE TO COME BACK TO THIS.
PARTICULAR BOAT. SIR DRAWS A
WORSE WE'RE SIMPLY TAKING UP THE
CONSENT ITEMS- CURRENTLY- THAT
WOULD BE SENT SB EIGHT FIFTY SP
NINE EIGHTY FOR THIS PROMOTION
BY SENATOR WHERE TO MOVE THOSE
TWO ITEMS. AND- WE WERE JUST
ABOUT TO CALL THE ROLL IF YOU'RE
PREPARED TO VOTE WILL PROCEED
WITH YOU PRESENT. SHE'S READY
OKAY THE- ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
NINETY FOUR ITEM SEVEN AS THE A.
FIFTY THE MOTION IS CONSENT.
COURTESY HI COURTESY I OR TO A
BOOK. A TRAVEL GUIDE RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I LAYERED HI LARRY I
NEWMAN NEWMAN NINE OKAY THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT. OF
THOSE BILLS. MOVE ON- WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK NOW TO S. B.
NINE FIFTY FOURTH THIS IS- ALSO
SENATOR ARSENAL IT IS BILL
CENTER IF YOU'RE PREPARED PLEASE
COME FORWARD. YOU MAY PRESENT
YOUR BILL. NINE FIFTY FOUR I
HOPE I STATED THE BILL NUMBER
THE BILL NUMBERS ARE VERY
SIMILAR. THANK HE.
THANK YOU SHARE I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS- WHAT AN
ARTIST TO BE IN OUR NEW BUILDING
AND DOING THIS IT'S ALL NEW TO
US FIRST COMMENT LOOKS LIKE THE
COURT ROOM. SO- I'M SURE SOME OF
US ARE ARE SO PROUD TO BE HERE.
RIGHT YOU'RE PROUD OF WE MIGHT
REALLY. WELL I'M I'M EXCITED TO
BE HERE RIGHT AND TODAY I
PRESENT A SENATE BILL NINE FIFTY
FOUR. TO REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO
ESTABLISH A DATABASE OF
ELECTRONIC CERTIFIED PAPER
RECORDS THAT IS ACCESSIBLE. TO
BOTH MULTI EMPLOYER HAVE HARDLY
TRUST FUNDS AND OR JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEES.
ESTABLISHED PURSUANT TO THE
FEDERAL LABOR MANAGEMENT
CORPORATION ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. IN INSTANCES WHEN
THE TAP HARD TO TRUST AND OR
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEES REQUEST PAPER RECORDS
EXISTING LAW AUTHORIZES THE
RELEASE OF THESE DOCUMENTS IN A
LESS RESTRICTIVE MANNER
REQUIRING THAT AWARDING BODIES
AND LABOR STANDARDS INCLUDE ALL
EMPLOYEES INFORMATION EXCEPT.
FOR THE FULL SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER. FOLLOWING A COMPLAINT
CURRENT PRACTICE REQUIRES THE
INITIATION OF A FORMER PUBLIC
WORKS INVESTIGATION WHERE THE
ASSIGNED DEPUTY MUST PERFORM A
VARIETY OF VEGETATIVE TASK
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
RESEARCH DOCKING MAILING INITIAL
FORMS AND ALL PARTIES AND TO ALL
PARTIES AND SETTING UP A
PHYSICAL CASE LOAD AND FILES.
OFTEN THESE CASES ARE CLOSED
WITH NO VIOLATIONS FOUND BECAUSE
THE CONTRACTOR FOLLOW THE LAW BY
PROVIDING THE RECORDS TO THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER ON A SET A
STATUTORILY REQUIRED DEADLINES.
THIS WASTE EFFORT RESOURCES AND
TIME AND MONEY THAT COULD BE
USED TO COMBAT VIOLATIONS THAT
ARE MORE SERIOUS. BECAUSE OF
THIS SENATE BILL NINE FIFTY FOUR
IS NEEDED TO ESTABLISH AN
EFFICIENT PROCESS FOR THE
RELEASE OF PUBLIC WORKS RECORDS
IN PAPER RECORDS BY ESTABLISHING
A STANDALONE THE DATABASE TO BE
EXCESSIVE ACCESSIBLE ONLY BY
TAFT HARTLEY TRUST FUNDS AND OR
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
WE WILL. BE AT WILL BE ENABLING
A MORE EFFICIENT FORM OF RECORD
ACCESS THAT WOULD LEAD TO
INCREASED LABOR COMPLIANCE
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS TO
CALCULATE EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS
AND SAVE TAXPAYER DOLLARS BY
DECREASING WORKLOAD OF AWARDING
AGENCIES AND THE DIVISION OF
LABOR STANDARDS AND ENFORCEMENT.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL IS
MATT AGREEMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS AND WHO IS
ALSO ABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ON BEHALF OF
THE HEAVY DUTY EQUIPMENT
OPERATORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND- MOVED MR CRIMMINS IF
YOU'RE- THANK YOU MISTER%
CHAIRMAN TELLS MAC MAC CRIMMINS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ABOUT A CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS WE ARE THE PROUD
SPONSORS OF SB NINE FIFTY FOUR.
AS A SENATOR STATED SP NINE
FIFTY FOUR IS INTENDED TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS BY WHICH
JOINTLY BY MANAGEMENT COMMITTEES
IN TAFT HARTLEY TRUST FUNDS
RECEIVE ACCESS TO ELECTRONIC
CERTIFIED PAYROLL ON PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS- IT'SEXTREMELY
IMPORTANT- RIGHT OFF THE BAT
THAT BOTH OF THESE ENTITIES ARE
ENTITLED COPIES OF THESE RECORDS
UNDER EXISTING LAW. ADDITIONALLY
EXISTING LAW FROM LAST YEAR
ESTABLISHED PURSUANT TO A B. TEN
TWENTY THREE BY SEVEN MEMBER HE
FLORA. MANDATED THAT ALL
CONTRACTORS ON PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS MUST PROVIDE ELECTRONIC
CERTIFIED PAYROLL RECORDS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ON A MONTHLY BASIS.
AND THE BILL ADDITIONALLY MADE
IT SO THERE WAS A PENALTY FOR
CONTRACTORS TO RELATE ON THIS
REQUIREMENT. SO WITH THAT IN
MIND AND CONSIDERING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WILL NOW HAVE THESE
RECORDS IN ELECTRONIC FORMAT. S.
B. NINE FIFTY FOUR WOULD SEEK TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS BY WHICH
JHELUM SEASON TAFT HARTLEY TRUST
RECEIVE ACCESS TO THESE RECORDS.
I'M AGAIN WE ARE NOT CREATING
ANY ANY NEW ACCESS TO THESE
RECORDS ANY OUTSIDE ENTITIES AND
WE'RE NOT PUTTING ANY NEW
REQUIREMENTS ON CONTRACTORS TO
PROVIDE THESE RECORDS WE'RE
SIMPLY LOOKING TO STREAMLINE THE
EXISTING PROCESS THAT THESE
ENTITIES USED TO GET IT. AND
WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST RIVAL THINK- I THINK MR
CRIMMINS IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WE WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS THE SUPPORT POSITION THIS BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD
AND IDENTIFY YOURSELF
AFFILIATION. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO LENT SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER WEST
ON THIS WITNESS. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT ON BEHALF
THE TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT WE
DON'T HAVE A LETTER IN BUT WE
WILL WORK ON THAT THANK. YOU
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER BROWN. THE
TERROR MEMBERS. JIM AVAILABLE
THE CALIBER LABOR FOR. AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEN
NONE WILL MOVE TO THE MODERATOR
NESS MODERATOR QUEUE UP. ANYONE
ON THE PHONE WITH SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AND THANK
YOU MR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COME IN AND SUPPORT
THE FIFTY NINE FIFTY OR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. FORGET IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FIFTY FOUR. MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO THANKS. FOR WE HAVE NO
CONCEPT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATOR WE
SHOW NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES OR ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS AN
OPPOSITION POSITION. SEEN NONE
OR WILL GO TO THE MODERATOR S.
MODERATOR- TO ASK THE SAME
QUESTION IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE WHO WISHES TO.
EXPRESS IN OPPOSE POSITION. AND
THANK YOU MR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN OFFICES ACROSS THE NINE FIFTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF
SB NINE FIFTY FOUR IMAGE PRESS
ONE CONDENSER. I HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO. COMMENT ON
THE BILL. YES SENATOR NEWMAN I
JUST WANT TO BREAK IN MY
MICROPHONE HERE AND SEE IT'S
NICE TO SEE EVERYBODY HERE- BUT
STARTS SO THAT AND THIS IS A
GOOD BILL TO MR COMES POINT THIS
IS. CLEARLY AN IDEA WHOSE TIME
IS COMING INCREASING THE CS.
THREE DOING THE RIGHT THING BY
WAY OF MODERNIZATION SO COMMEND
YOU ON THE BILL- AND HAPPY TO
MOVE IT WHEN THE TIME'S.
APPROPRIATE OKAY HERE ANYONE
ELSE WITHOUT A SOBER BUSTER
MEANING IN DID YOU WANT TO SPEAK. OKAY SHE SAID GONNA PASS ON
ANY COMMENTS BUT I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER- OTHER- TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. WITH WISHING TO
RECOGNIZE. SENATOR SENATOR
NEWMAN HAS MOVED THE BILL BUT
BEFORE WE CALL THE ROLL CALL
CENTER ACTUALLY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I THANK YOU ALL AND I-
RESPECTFULLY AFTER I BOOK THANK
YOU IN THE CONSULTANT OF PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CALL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY HI OR DOES HE DIE OR
TROUBLE. THE TROUBLE NO THE
RUSSELL. RUSSELL I LAYERED HI
LARRY I NEWMAN NEWMAN I. OKAY
THAT BILL WAS OUT ON A FOUR TO
ONE VOTE- WITH THE INDULGENCE OF
THE COMMITTEE I JUST WANT TO GO
BACK- INTO GET CENTER DRAWS
ATTENTION ON THE FIRST BILL WE
TOOK UP AND WITH THE CALL WHICH
WAS PRESENTED BY SUNDERLAND S.
B. NINE THIRTY ONE THE CONSOLE
CAN YOU. CALL YES. AT S. B. NINE
THIRTY ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY THE
RUSSELL. RUSSELL I IT HAS A FOUR
ONE RIGHT THE BILL IS NOW OUT ON
A FOUR TO ONE VOTE- WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO. THE NEXT BILL- WHICH
IS- SENATOR ATKINS. BILL SB
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN THAT IS
GOING TO BE PRESENTED BY YOURS
TRULY AND- I GUESS UNDER THIRTY
CLEANER CODE PROTOCOLS I CAN-
PRESENT FROM UP HERE BUT I'M
GONNA PASS THE GAVEL IN THE
MEANTIME- AT LEAST FIGURATIVELY
TO THE VICE CHAIR SO SHE CAN.
RUN THE MEETING DURING THE
COURSE OF THIS BILL. BY SHOW TO
A BOOK. I'LL TURN OVER TO
. FOR
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WHAT AN HONOR
. FOR BREAKING MY MICROPHONE AS
WELL- NEXT WE'LL HAVE S. B. ONE
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN WHICH WILL
BE PRESENTED ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR ATKINS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MR KERRY YOU LIKE TO
RECEIVE. THANK YOU- MEMBERS-
EMENTA BY SECURITY MY PLEASURE
TO PRESENT S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN BEHALF APPROACH AMERICANS
WHICH WILL PROVE THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM FOR INJURED
PUBLIC SAFETY WORKERS SO THEY
MAY ACCESS THE CARE THEY NEED
AND DESERVE AND DESERVE- IN IN
OF COURSE TO CONTINUE PROTECTING
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE FIREFIGHTERS
AND POLICE OFFICERS PUT
THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY EACH
AND EVERY DAY THE REPORT TO
DUTY. TO PROTECT THESE WORKERS A
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTIONS IN THE
WORKERS COMP SYSTEM TO
STREAMLINE CERTAIN CLAIMS REDUCE
FRICTIONAL COSTS WITHIN THE
SYSTEM. THIRD EXPEDITIOUS
ADJUDICATION OF THESE CLAIMS
BENEFITS THE WORKERS SEEKING
TREATMENT AND THEIR EMPLOYERS
SAVING ADDITIONAL PERSONAL COST
TO BACKFILL THE INJURED
FIREFIGHTER. MINIMUM SALARY
REQUIREMENTS FOR FIRE
DEPARTMENTS MEANS EACH DAY OF
FIREFIGHTERS OUT WITH AN INJURY
OR ILLNESS ANOTHER FIREFIGHTER
MUST COVER HIS OR HER SHIFT.
OFTEN RESULTING IN OVERTIME TO
BACKFILL THE INJURED FIREFIGHTER
GROSSLY. TODAY INJURED WORKERS
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE DELAYS
AND DENIALS THAT PREVENT THEIR
CLAIMS AND ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CARE FOR MOVING FORWARD IN A
TIMELY MANNER. S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN REDUCES THE TIME
LINE FOR ACCEPTANCE OR DENIAL OF
INJURY CLAIMS. PRESUMPTIVE OR
OTHERWISE AND IT JUST PENALTIES
FOR EMPLOYERS INSURERS AND THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATORS. THAT
UNREASONABLY DENIED. PRESUMPTIVE
INJURY CLAIMS S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN IT SURE IS A
TEMPORARY DISABILITY AWARDED FOR
CANCER CLAIM IS ADEQUATE. TO
PROTECT THE INJURED FIREFIGHTER
OVERTIME. AS HE BATTLED THEIR
ILLNESS BY REMOVING THE STATUE
LIMITATIONS FOR CANCER CLEANS
AND BY ALLOWING UP TO TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY COMPENSABLE
WEEKS FOR THOSE SUFFERING FROM
OCCUPATIONAL CANCER. WHERE THE
CANCER. HAS CAUSED A TEMPORARY
DISABILITY. OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCE
CATASTROPHIC WALL FIGHTERS
PLAYERS THAT HAVE TAKEN A HUGE
TOLL ON FIREFIGHTERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. FOURTEEN OF THE
LARGEST TWENTY WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY FOUR IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ALONE HAVE
OCCURRED IN THE PAST TEN YEARS
CAUSING TENS OF BILLIONS IN
INSURANCE PAYOUTS AND ECONOMIC
DAMAGE. URBAN RURAL FIREFIGHTERS
ARE EXPOSED TO THE DEVASTATION
OF HOMES AND TOWNS HUMAN
SUFFERING AND TRAUMA THE
INTEREST CONDITIONS AND EXTREME
FATIGUE. THIS IS OUR NEW NORMAL
. AND AS SUCH THE LEGISLATURE IS
BEING CALLED UPON TO UPDATE THIS
IMPORTANT ONE OR TO PROTECT
FRONTLINE HEROES. THIS BILL
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
A FAIR AND REAL POSITIVE CHANGE
IN THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
SYSTEM TO STRENGTHEN OUR
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT THOSE. WHO
PROTECT US EACH AND EVERY DAY.
WITH ME TO PRESENT THIS BILL. IN
PERSON IS BRIAN RICE PRESENT.
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS THE SPONSORS OF SB. ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. IN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK REGARDING SB ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN MY NAME'S BRIAN RICE AND
THE PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS THEY
REPRESENT MORE THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND PARAMEDICS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR CORTEZ C. AND
SENATOR PRO TEM ATKINS AND ALL
THE CO AUTHORS OF THIS MEASURE
FOR THE LEADERSHIP ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. WORKERS
COMPENSATION PRESUMPTIVE'S
EARNING VALUABLE PROTECTION FOR
FIREFIGHTERS AND OTHER WORKERS
WHOSE JOBS ARE INHERENTLY
DANGEROUS AND COME WITH MORE
PERSONAL RISK RIGHT NOW
FIREFIGHTERS ARE NOT
EXPERIENCING THAT IT KNOWLEDGE
MEANT WHEN DEALING WITH THE
PRESUMPTIVE INJURY OR ILLNESS.
IT'S MORE COMMON NOW FOR AN
EMPLOYER THEIR INSURER OR THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR TO INITIALLY
DIDN'T DENY A PRESUMPTIVE CLAIM
FACING NO MATERIAL RISK. OF
INCURRING PENALTIES IF THE CLAIM
IS ULTIMATELY ACCEPTED. INJURED
FIREFIGHTERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
ARE CARRYING THE PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL COST OF UNREASONABLE
DENIALS. AND THEY'RE BEING ASKED
TO SPEND THEIR TIME FIGHTING
THEIR ILLNESS AND THE SYSTEM AND
TO WHAT END. S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN PROPOSES TO ADDRESS THESE
UNFAIR PRACTICES BY REFORMING
THE PENALTY STRUCTURES AND
TIMELINES REGARDING THE
TERMINATION THE DETERMINATION
FOR COMPENSATE ABILITY. BY
INCREASING THE PENALTIES FOR AN
ACTION DEEMED BY A JUDGE TO BE
UNEXPLAINED AND REASONABLE
DENIAL OF PRESUMPTIVE BENEFITS.
LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST SP
TWENTY SEVEN WILL ENSURE THAT
FIREFIGHTERS WHO HAVE A
REOCCURRING CANCER DO NOT HAVE
TO RESET THE CLOCK FOR TEMPORARY
DISABILITY PROTECTIONS TO RUN
OUT. YOU'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT PROVISION FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FIRE LIEUTENANT CD.
NOW THE OPPOSITION MAY CLAIM
THAT THEY HAVE REVIEWED THE DATA
AND THEY'RE NOT PROBLEMS THAT
OCCURRED WITHIN THE SYSTEM IF
THAT'S THE CASE WHY CAN I
PERSONALLY NAME MORE
FIREFIGHTERS THAN I CARE TO
COUNT WHO'VE BEEN FIGHTING. BUT
THEIR DENIALS OVER WORK COMP
CLAIMS FOR WELL WELL OVER A YEAR
MOREOVER IF THESE PARTIES ARE
REASONABLY DENYING CLAIMS THEN
WHY ARE THERE CONCERNS BEING
RAISED ABOUT THE PENALTY
PROVISIONS. THE LIKELY ALSO SAY
THAT NINETY DAYS IS NOT LONG
ENOUGH TO PROCESS THESE CLAIMS
AND PRESUMPTIVE CLAIMS ARE ALL
GRANTED ANYWAY. IF THAT WAS THE
CASE WHY IS A COMMON OCCURRENCE
FOR THESE CASES TO BE LEFT TO
THE SURVIVING SPOUSE OF A
FIREFIGHTER. WHO HAS DIED OF JOB
RELATED ILLNESS BECAUSE IT WAS
NOT SETTLED WHY THEY WERE STILL
ALIVE. GIVEN TECHNOL TECHNOLOGY
IMPROVEMENTS WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO SPEED UP CONSIDERATION OF
COMPENSATE ABILITY AND S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN WAS SURE
THAT. THE STATUS QUO CANNOT
CONTINUE. CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS ARE BEING ABANDONED ALL
FIREFIGHTERS WANT TO DO IN IT IF
YOU ASK THEM. EVERY FIREFIGHTER
I'VE EVER KNOWN THAT'S BEEN
INJURED OR ILL. YEAH SOMEONE
QUESTION IN ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'VE BEEN INJURED THE FIRST
THING THEY ASK YOU IS WHEN CAN I
GO BACK TO WORK. I SPOKE TO. A
WORKERS COMP ATTORNEY THAT WE'VE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH THIS
DEADLY PHOENIX TWENTY FOUR OF
THE TWENTY EIGHT PRESUMPTIVE.
ILLNESS CASES THAT HE HOLDS OR
OVER A YEAR OLD IN DENIAL. THERE
IS A PROBLEM AND LAST BUT NOT
LEAST I'LL TAKE THIS FROM
SENATOR LEYVA WHO IS JUST IN
HERE. IT'S REALLY VERY SIMPLE
DON'T GO OVER THE TIME LINE AND
DON'T GET FINED. WE NEED YOUR
HELP I STRONGLY URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO PASS THIS SP ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN THROUGH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE ALSO HAVE A IT IS HERE
2% OUR- IS A BRAIN RICE. I WAS
RAISED RICE I'M SORRY LIEUTENANT
MY GUY LISA SIDE SADIE. IT IS IN
HE'S- HE SHOULD BE ON THE
MODERATORS- WINE OR THE OVER
THERE'S THIS CODE PART AROUND
HIS ESTIMATE OF SORRY I
APOLOGIZE FROM THE AT TELEPHONE.
YES PLEASE PROCEED. HELLO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
THIS AFTERNOON REGARDING XP
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. MY NAME IS
LUKE ALWAYS AT AND I AM A TWENTY
THREE YEAR VETERAN OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO FIRE DEPARTMENT. I
WILL I HAVE SPENT MY CAREER IN
BUSY URBAN STATIONS RESPONDING
TO FIRES AND OTHER EMERGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE CITY. I WAS FIRST
DIAGNOSED WITH BREAST CANCER IN
EARLY TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
DURING A ROUTINE MAMMOGRAM
SCREENING. DURING MY INITIAL
PERIOD OF TREATMENT MY FOCUS WAS
ON MY HEALTH AND MY FAMILY AND
MAKING SURE THAT I CAN GET BACK
TO WORK AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
I USE THE TEMPORARY DISABILITY
TIME THAT WAS AVAILABLE TO ME TO
SEEK TREATMENT AND AFTER
SUCCESSFUL IMPACT IN THE
PROCEDURES AND RADIATION. I WAS
DECLARED CANCER FREE. AFTER A
CLEAN BILL OF HEALTH FOR FOUR
YEARS I WAS UNFORTUNATELY FOUND
TO HAVE BREAST CANCER ONCE
AGAIN. IS TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
SPREAD MY CANCER MEANT THAT THIS
TIME I WOULD NEED A DOUBLE
MASTECTOMY. IT WAS DURING MY
SECOND BOUT WITH CANCER THAT I
WAS INFORMED THAT MY- TEMPORARY
DISABILITY TIME HAD EXPIRED.
SOMETHING THAT I DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW WAS POSSIBLE AND THAT ADDED
ADDITIONAL STRESS AND
UNCERTAINTY TO AN ALREADY
DIFFICULT TIME. BECAUSE THIS
CANCER WAS DETERMINED TO BE A
QUOTE UNQUOTE REOCCURRENCE. OF
THE PREVIOUS BREAST CANCER I
COULDN'T FILE FOR ADDITIONAL
TEMPORARY DISABILITY LEAVING ME
WITHOUT OPTIONS OTHER THAN TO
USE MY OWN VACATION AND MY OWN
THICK TURN FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD. THE SURGERY AND HEALING
TIME FOR A DOUBLE MASTECTOMY IS
EXPENSIVE AND IT IS ONLY BECAUSE
OF MY MANY YEARS ON THE JOB AND
CAREFULLY SAVING MYTIME. THAT I
WAS ABLE TO COVER IT ALL.
ANOTHER FIREFIGHTER MAY NOT BE
SO LUCKY I HAVE GOTTEN THROUGH
MY EXPERIENCE WITH THE SUPPORT
OF MY FAMILY AND MY BROTHERS AND
SISTERS IN THE FIRE DEPARTMENT.
BUT NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THINGS LIKE THE EXPIRATION
DATE OF THEIR DISABILITY TIME.
WHILE BATTLING CANCER. AS
FIREFIGHTERS WE ARE EXPOSED TO
ALL KINDS OF TOXIC MATERIALS.
THAT ARE KNOWN TO INCREASE THE
RISK OF CANCER. BUT WE FACE AS
WELL ANYWAY BECAUSE WE LOVE OUR
JOBS. AND SERVING OUR
COMMUNITIES. THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW MY BROTHERS AND SISTERS TO
FOCUS. ON GETTING BETTER WITHOUT
WORRYING ABOUT WHETHER THEY WILL
BE LUCKY ENOUGH TO GET SICK.
AGAIN WITHIN THE TIME THE RIGHT
TIME FRAME OR WHETHER THEY WILL
BE LEFT. WITH NO RECOURSE IF
IT'S TOO LATE FOR THESE REASONS
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND KIND. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- BREYER COMPELLING-
INVULNERABILITY IN SHARING YOUR
TESTIMONY WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO
ANYONE WANTING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT- DO WE HAVE ANYONE HERE
IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO-
THAT'S FACT. PROCEED HELLO
JENNIFER MILEY CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION OF SUPPORT THANK YOU
. MATT BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT. ANYONE ELSE. THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
877-226-8160 THREE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN SIX TWO
TWO FOUR SIX YOU AND I APOLOGIZE
PROBABLY SAID THAT A LITTLE FAST
WE HAVE THAT ON THE SCREEN OR
SHOULD I REPEAT THAT NUMBER.
YEAH THE NUMBER AGAIN IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TWO MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE ONE
TWO SEVEN WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES
FROM THE LINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RANDY PERRY
WITH THEIR READERS- SITS ON
BEHALF AT CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HYPERTROPHY. PORAC AND THE
CALIFORNIA CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTERS
ON PRINCIPLE. SUPPORT CO
SPONSORED THE BILL THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M ACTUALLY HERE FOR
ANOTHER GIRL. THANK YOU. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NINE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DATA ON BEHALF OF THE LA COUNTY
. AND OF COURSE. ONE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
READY MIX THAT CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY RIGHT FROM SUPPORT.
NINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHICH IS
YOUR MCALLISTER I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HAVE YOU HEARD FROM
ALL THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOT
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FROM THE OPPOSITION- DO WE HAVE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. S. ONE THREE. OKAY THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE- TO LEAD OFFICE AT
WHICH IS NOT POSITION WILL BEGIN
WITH FAITH LANE GORGEOUS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES PLEASE
PROCEED MISFORTUNES. S. WHICH
PLACES WITHOUT OKAY WITH THAT'S
OKAY NO PROBLEM ARE YOU MISTER
JAMES MR YES NOTHING ELSE SIR
YEAH- WITH CALIFORNIA COALITION
ON WORKERS COMPOSITION OF PUBLIC
RISK INNOVATION SOLUTIONS AND
MANAGEMENT PERFECT THIS RECEIPT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- J. CENTRAL TO HEAR
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
ON WORKERS COMPENSATION AND
PRISM PUBLIC RISK INNOVATION
SOLUTIONS AND MANAGEMENT WHICH
IS A GPA THAT DOESN'T TURN
SERVICES FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
FEW THINGS TO KNOW RIGHT OFF-
RIGHT AT THE BEGINNING THAT I
WANT YOU TO KEEP IN MIND. AS I'M
AS I'M TALKING ONE THE BILL
DOESN'T APPLY ONLY TO
FIREFIGHTERS IN PEACE OFFICERS
IT DOESN'T. APPLY ONLY TO
PRESUMPTION CLAIMS AT A PRICE
THAT APPLIES TO ALL CLAIMS IN
VARIOUS PROVISIONS CERTAIN
pCLAIMS. BUT IT IS NOT A NEARLY A
FIREFIGHTER PEACE OFFICER BILL.
SO I'M GONNA FOCUS ON THE
PROVISION THAT REDUCES THE TIME
FRAME- THE SPONSOR IS CORRECT- I
MEAN MESSAGE TODAY IS GOING TO
BE THAT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH TIME
AFFORDED BY THE BILL. SO A FEW
THINGS FOR YOU TO KEEP IN MIND-
THIS BILL WAS STUDIED- THE
PRECURSOR BILL WAS STUDIED- SP
THREE THIRTY FIVE LAST YEAR- SI
WCI THE CALIFORNIA. WORKERS
COMPENSATION INSTITUTE DID A
BRIEF. PERCENT OF CLAIMS
ROUGHLY- ACCEPTED WITHIN THE
NINETY DAYS CURRENTLY- BY DAY
NINETY. 97% OF CLAIMS ARE
ACCEPTED SO THERE ARE SOME THAT
GO BEYOND THE NINETY DAYS
USUALLY. I'LL TALK ABOUT THIS IN
A MINUTE IT'S A RESULT OF THE
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE TO
UNDERTAKE- YOU REDUCE THAT TO
FORTY FIVE DAYS AND- ONLY 84% OF
CLAIMS- HAVE A- HAVE A DECISION.
BUT THAT'S FOR ALL CLAIMS IF YOU
LOOK AT CLAIMS ARE TONIGHT WHICH
ARE DENIED- AT FORTY FIVE DAYS
ONLY 37% OF THEM HAVE A DECISION
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE AND THIS IS
FOR A REASON. I'M ONE OF THE
CLAIMS THAT ARE POTENTIALLY
GOING TO BE TONIGHT OR PROBABLY
THE MORE COMPLEX CLAIMS. OF
MEDICALLY AND FACTUALLY OKAY SO
WE HAVE TO DO AN ACTUAL
INVESTIGATION- THAT IS DETAILED
IN NATURE. AND THEN SECOND THE
LAWS AND THE REGULATIONS OF THE
STATE. DICTATE THE PROCESS OF
THE INVESTIGATION AND I'M GONNA
WALK YOU THROUGH THAT NOW.
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT ALLOW US TO
CONDUCT. AN INVESTIGATION AND
THIRTY OR SIXTY DAYS. SO I'M
FIRST AND FOREMOST- THE
REGULATIONS REQUIRE THAT
EMPLOYERS- PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE INVESTIGATION WE
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO RESTRICT THE
INVESTIGATION ONLY. TO PREPARING
OBJECTIONS WE NEED TO LOOK AT
ALL OF THE INFORMATION WE MUST
FULLY AND FAIRLY. GATHER ALL OF
THE PERTINENT INFORMATION- AND
WHETHER IT REQUIRES OR EXCUSES
BENEFITS. AND THEN WE'VE GOT TO
DOCUMENT ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION- IN CASE OF
LITIGATION OR INVESTIGATION FROM
THE STATE OKAY. SO WHAT IS THE
INVESTIGATION LOOK LIKE- WE DO
PHONE INTERVIEWS WITH THE
INJURED WORKER THE EMPLOYER.
WITNESS SAYS- THE DOCTOR- WE
SEND THE INJURED WORKER A
MEDICAL RELEASE FORM TO OBTAIN
PRIOR RELEVANT MEDICAL
INFORMATION THAT CAN TAKE SOME
TIME TO COME BACK- AND THEN
ULTIMATELY IF THE IF THE CLAIM
IS GOING TO BE. DENIED BASED ON
A MEDICAL REASON YOU'VE GOT TO
GO THROUGH THE STATE'S MEDICAL
LEGAL PROCESS OKAY SO WHAT DOES
THAT PROCESS LOOK LIKE. THE
PARTY'S REQUEST A PANEL OF
DOCTORS FROM THE STATE THE STATE
THEN ENDS US THAT PANEL W
SELECT THE DOCTOR SCHEDULE AN
APPOINTMENT RECEIVE. THE REPORT
OKAY BUT THERE'S MORE TO IT SO
HERE'S- WHAT THE REGULATIONS AND
STATUTES SAY TODAY AND THIS IS
UNCHANGED BY THE CURRENT BILL.
ONCE A CLAIM IS FILED THE WORKER
HAS TEN DAYS TO REQUEST THE
PANEL ON THE ROOM BEFORE WE
CAN'T SO TEN DAYS GOES BY BEFORE
WE CAN EVEN REQUEST THE PANEL.
THE STATE THEN HAS TEN DAYS TO
SEND US THE PANEL. THEN WE HAVE
THE EMPLOYEE HAS TEN DAYS TO
PICK A DOCTOR BEFORE WE CAN
PICK. THE THIRTY DAYS IS OVER
RIGHT THERE. UNDER THE SPELL ON
PRESUMPTIVE CLAIMS. IT'S DONE WE
CAN NO LONGER PROCEED THE THIRTY
DAYS IS OVER WE HAVEN'T EVEN
GOTTEN THROUGH THE BEGINNING OF
THE STATE'S PROCESS. ONCE A
DOCTOR IS SELECTED AN
APPOINTMENT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
SCHEDULED WITHIN SIXTY DAYS. AND
THEN A REP A MEDICAL REPORT IS
DELIVERED THIRTY DAYS AFTER
THAT. SO WE'RE A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS INTO THE PROCESS
JUST BASED ON THE STATE
REGULATORY STRUCTURE THIS ISN'T
AN EMPLOYER STRUCTURE THIS IS
THE LEGISLATURE STRUCTURE AND
IT'S THE- DIVISION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION STRUCTURE. ON TOP
OF THAT THE STATE AUDITOR DID A
PANEL AT. AN AUDIT OF THE Q. I.
ME PROCESS A FEW YEARS AGO- AND
FOUND THAT DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THERE WERE- THE NUMBER OF-
INCREASE WERE UP THIRTY. THE
NUMBER OF PANEL REQUESTS WAS
INCREASED THIRTY SEVEN PERCENT.
THE NUMBER OF DOCTORS AVAILABLE
WAS DOWN TWELVE PERCENT. THE
PROCESS IS MOVING SLOWER AND THE
REPORT QUALITY IS SLOW. SO THIS
IS THE PROCESS THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY WHAT EMPLOYERS ARE
CHOOSING TO DO IT IS A STATE RUN
PROCESS WITH STATE RULES. AND WE
SIMPLY ADHERE TO IT. MMHM THE
CURRENT BILL CHANGES NONE OF
THESE DETAILS IT SIMPLY SAYS DO
IT FASTER WITHOUT PROVIDING ANY
RELIEF. FOR THE PROCESS THAT
EXISTS IN STATE LAW NOW SO WITH
THAT- RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
REGISTER MY OPPOSITION AND URGE
YOUR NOTEBOOK TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR. ARSENAL
CERTAIN THAT WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO OUR SECOND LEAD WITNESS. I'M
IN OPPOSITION FAITH LANE FORCES
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY.
WELCOME AND THANK YOU SHERRIN
MEMBER STATE BORDERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES. GPS OR
THE NOT FOR PROFIT MECHANISM
THAT MOST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS USE
TO EFFECTIVELY SELL FUNDS ARE
WORKERS COMPENSATION INSURANCE.
AT THE GOAL OF PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
IS TO HELP ALL INJURED WORKERS
RECEIVE APPROPRIATE CARE AND
RETURN BACK TO WORK AS SOON AS
THEY ARE SAFELY ABLE TO DO SO.
THIS BILL DRAMATICALLY DECREASES
STATUTORY TIME FRAMES. FOR AN
EMPLOYER TO OBTAIN NECESSARY
INFORMATION TO APPROVE.
APPROPRIATE WORKERS COMPENSATION
CLAIMS AND DENY FRAUDULENT
CLAIMS. DURING THE PERIOD OF
DETERMINATION OF BENEFITS.
EMPLOYERS FINED UP TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN MEDICAL CARE
FOR INJURED WORKERS EVEN IF THE
CLAIM IS ULTIMATELY DENIED.
WITHOUT NECESSARY MEDICAL
RECORDS AND MEDICAL EVALUATIONS
EMPLOYERS MAY BE FORCED TO DENY
CLAIMS. WHICH HOLDS EMPLOYER
FUNDED MEDICAL CARE WHICH CAUSES
A NIGHTMARE FOR THE INJURED
WORKER AND INCREASES. FRICTION
WITHIN THE SYSTEM IN LITIGATION.
ALL EMPLOYERS ARE BOUND BY
STATUTORY AND REGULAR REGULATORY
PROCEEDINGS AS YOU JUST HEARD.
MANY OF WHICH ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
EMPLOYERS CONTROL. THE SYSTEM
REQUIRES PARTICIPATION FROM THE
INJURED WORKER. TOURNEY'S AND
THE MEDICAL PROVIDERS. AN
INTERNAL REVIEW OF CLAIMS OVER%
THE LAST TWO YEARS SHOWED THAT
NEARLY 20% OF DENIALS. WERE DUE
TO THE INJURED WORKERS REFUSAL
TO PROVIDE A STATEMENT OR SIGN A
MEDICAL RELEASE. 20% OF DENIALS
WERE DUE TO NEGATIVE CODED
TESTS. 20% OF DENIALS WERE DUE
TO THE PHYSICIANS INDICATION
THAT THEY COULD NOT CONFIRM A
DIAGNOSIS OF THE STATED INJURY.
OR THAT THE INJURY WAS WORK
RELATED. 27% OF DENIALS ARE
BECAUSE THAT RECORDS OR DAILY
RATIONS COULD NOT BE OBTAINED
WITHIN THE STATUTORY NINETY
DAYS. THESE REASONS BECAUSE AN
ADMINISTRATOR TO PROVISIONALLY
DENY A CLAIM. UNTIL THEY HAVE A
CONFIRMED DIAGNOSIS OF
INDUSTRIAL. CAUSATION SO WE WERE
WELCOME FURTHER CON. ON THIS AT
HIS. THE SYSTEM DOES WORK TO
ENSURE THAT ANY WORKER WITH AN
INDUSTRIAL INJURY RECEIVED
MEDICAL TREATMENT AT NO COST TO
THE WORKER. RECENT REPORTS SHOW
THAT 90% OF ALL CLAIMS ARE
ACCEPTED IMMEDIATELY AND THE
NUMBER IS HIGHER FOR
FIREFIGHTERS. THE ALL PRESENTED
CASES EVEN THE CODE CLAIMS FOR
NINE AM PUBLIC EMPLOYERS THE
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT ARE COVERED
BY PRESUMPTIONS ARE LARGELY
PUBLIC EMPLOYERS. AS AMENDED
THIS BILL WOULD MANDATE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RECEIVED FIVE TIMES
THE AMOUNT OF BENEFITS THAT
PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYEES
RECEIVED FOR THE STEAM INJURIES
. SINCE THERE IS NO DEFINITION
OF UNREASONABLE DENIAL EACH
DENIAL OF A REBUTTABLE.
PRESUMPTION MAY BE LITIGATED AS
UNREASONABLE AND ADDED MINIMUM
THIS DRASTICALLY INCREASES THE
COST OF ALL TO ALL EMPLOYERS.
AND HEARINGS TO ADDRESS THESE
PENALTY POSITIONS WILL DELAY
JUDY CATION OF WORKERS CLAIMED.
BY LIMITING THE INVESTIGATION
PERIOD TO THIRTY DAYS AT ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN HAMSTRINGS
EMPLOYERS INVESTIGATIONS OF BOTH
APPROPRIATE AND QUESTIONABLE
WORKERS COMPENSATION CLAIMS. ALL
THAT GUARANTEEING LEGALLY
INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO
APPROPRIATE LEGITIMATE CLAIMS OR
DENIED INVALID FRAUDULENT CLAIMS
AND THEN IT PENALIZES THE
EMPLOYER FOR DOING A GOOD JOB ON
THE INVESTIGATION. ULTIMATELY
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE
ABBREVIATED TIME FRAME WILL
INCREASE CLAIM DENIALS FOSTER
INCREASED AND UNNECESSARY
LITIGATION DRIVER CLAIMS COSTS
AND ULTIMATELY NEGATIVELY IMPACT
INJURED WORKERS. WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO MEET
WITH US AND OUT OF THE SPONSOR
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS BUT AT THIS TIME
WE REMAIN RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISS LANE
GORGEOUS AND WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES HERE ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CLAIMS
PROFESSIONALS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON
ASHLEY HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE MEMBERS ERIN AVERY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THE FREE MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE BRIAN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN RESPECT LOVE
SYSTEM FOR THE REASONS STATED BY
MR NELSON MISS LANE THANK YOU.
RIPPING ANYONE ELSE. INTO
OPPOSITION. TWO S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN HEARING ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WENT TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN WILL BE KEPT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
THE OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
RIGHT FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU. FIVE FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HERE IN BREAKING WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT CALLED ON
BEHALF OF BETA HEALTHCARE GROUP
BUT EVEN WITH IT ALSO. THANK YOU
. BY NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DAVE BUTLER ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED CHAMBER ADVOCACY NETWORK
COALITION OF SEVEN LOCAL
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE AND THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. ONE FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
DOROTHY JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
MINISTRY- IS RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
. ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOHNNY
PENA WITH LEGAL CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU DON'T
NEED YOUR MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE RUNNING RADIO HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION- IN
OPPOSITION YES WE WENT FROM
SEVEN AND ECHO THE COMMENTS-
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MEMBER
MODERATOR. THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MEMBERS. DO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. MR HERE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I DON'T
THINK AMENABLE SURE- IN A THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO RESENT- PRO TEM
ATKINS BILL CENTER RECKONS BILL-
I'M A RO CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL
I'M I DO WANT TO- TO CLARIFY
THAT- THE THIRD PART OF THIS
BILL AS IT WAS PRESENTED- A FEW
MINUTESAGO WHEN I'M IN THE
PRESENTATION. HAS ONLY TO DO
WITH UNREASONABLE DENIALS
UNREASONABLE DENIALS AND THE
PENALTIES THEREFORE ON
PRESUMPTION CLAIMS THAT ARE
ALREADY CODIFIED AS PRESUMPTION
CLAIMS- IN DONE THE TEMP THE
SECOND POINT. I MADE WAS TO HAD
TO DO WITH TEMPORARY DISABILITY
AWARDED FOR CANCER- THAT'S
RIGHT. CURRENTLY IN EXISTENCE-
WITH THAT PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL
FIREFIGHTER. INTO THE TIMELINE
SO I THINK- FOR THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ACTUALLY STATED VERY
CLEARLY THAT- THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL HAS KEPT AN OPEN DOOR IN
TERMS OF- CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS
ON THE BILL SO WITHOUT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CHAIR DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON SP ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN SO MOVED. THANK YOU
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
FIRST REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY. HI
COURTESY I OR TROUBLE NO BUT
TROUBLED KNOW WRESTLE. LAYERED
NEWMAN NEWMAN I WILL PUT THAT
BILL ON THE CALL FOR OUR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
FIFTY FIFTY. GREAT THANK YOU
MA'AM BYE SURE. WE WILL MOVE ON
TO- THE NEXT BILL IN ORDER AND-
THAT IS. S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR MCGUIRE I SEE
THAT HE'S PRESIDENT SENATOR
MCGUIRE- IF YOU'RE PREPARED YOU
MAY PRESENT AT THIS TIME WELCOME. MR HEARING COMMITTEE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
WITH YOU TODAY I'M VERY GRATEFUL
I WANT TO START OUT BY SAYING
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR. OUT FOR THE TREMENDOUS
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ALSO I SAY THANK YOU
TO THE INCREDIBLE STAFF OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR AMAZING WORK
AND OF. COURSE MR HERE WE'RE
GONNA BE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT
IS OUT IN THE- AND AGAIN I.
TRULY APPRECIATE YOUR SINCERE. I
THINK THAT WE CAN ALL SAY THAT
THE WAY IS WHY. AT ATROCITIES
TAKING PLACE IN YOUR WITH WHOLE.
IT'S IT MAKES ME ANGRY AN
OUTRAGE AND INCREDIBLY SET.
RUSSIA'S COMMENCE UNPROVOKED
DEVASTATING WAR ON THE NATION OF
UKRAINE THAT IS CAUSE
INDISCRIMINATE KILLING OF
CIVILIANS. BOMBING OF WHOLE
CITIES WE KNOW WHAT PUTIN'S GOAL
IS TO WIPE THEM OFF THE FACE OF
THIS EARTH. THE DISLOCATION OF
OVER A MILLION REFUGEES.
MILLIONS MORE ON THE WAY. IN
MONUMENTAL DISRUPTION TO
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS. I THINK
THAT WE CAN SAY WITH THIS BILL
WE CAN STAND STRONG WITH THE
PEOPLE OF UKRAINE IN FACT FIFTY
SEVEN MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
OF ALL COME ON AS CO AUTHORS IS
BILL NO MATTER IF YOU'RE
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT. YES THE
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT IS A
CRITICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
REQUIRING PENSION SYSTEMS.
PUBLIC PENSION SYSTEMS INCLUDING
THE TWO LARGEST HERE IN AMERICA
STIRS IN PERS. DIVEST. FROM
RUSSIAN AND BELARUSIAN ASSETS.
IN
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT. IN.
ENACTING THEIR OWN FINANCIAL
DIVESTMENTS. RUSSIA'S ECONOMY IS
NOT EVEN THE- TEN WORLD. AND
IT'S ONE OF THE BIG PRESSURE PER
THAT WE CAN PUT ON. CALIFORNIA
SHE YOU ITS POWER. TO EXERT IN.
IN CALIFORNIA AS WELL TO DIVEST
THEIR INVESTMENTS IN THE RUSSIAN
ECONOMY. IN ADDITION SP THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT BLOCKS THE AWARDING
OF STATE CONTRACTS TO ANY
COMPANY THAT IS CONDUCTING
BUSINESS WITHIN RUSSIA. THE BILL
AS I SAID MR CARE SUPPORTED BY
BROAD AND GROWING BIPARTISAN
COALITION OF SENATORS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS INCLUDING OF
COURSE SURE CORTESE WHEN I SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH DEVICE
CHURCHILL A BOAT. ONCE A THANK
YOU TO SENATOR NEWMAN AND OF
COURSE SENATOR DR SO AND AGAIN
FIFTY SEVEN TOTAL MEMBERS OF
THIS LEGISLATURE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS ALIKE STANDING
STRONG IN DOING THE RIGHT THING
AND I'VE SEEN THIS TWO BILLION
DOLLARS OUT OF RUSSIA AND
BELARUS. AT THIS POINT THERE IS
NO EXCUSE TO INVEST IN AND
SUPPORT PUTTING HIS OLIGARCHS IN
THE RUSSIAN ECONOMY RESPECTFULLY
ASKS AND I VOTE IN MISTER CHAIR-
IF YOU WOULD ALLOW WE HAVE
BRITNEY BARZANI THE CALIFORNIA
NEWSPAPER ASSOCIATION THERE
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR LONG TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY. A RIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR
AND- THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FORD CENTER FOR SAUDI. AND-
NOT YET NOT YET NO- GRITTY BARS
NOT HAPPEN AT SOME POINT. OKAY
JUST- BRITNEY BAR SITE GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR TERROR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- I AM PLEASED TO
STAND IN SUPPORT WAS SENATOR
MCGUIRE ON S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT. THE MPA REPRESENTS OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED NEWS PUBLICATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA AND CONTINUOUSLY
FIGHTS TO PROTECT JOURNALISTS
AND THE CRITICAL ROLE OF THE
PRESS AND COMMUNICATING THE
TRUTH TO THE PUBLIC. ON MANY
ISSUES INCLUDING THE TRUTH ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN RUSSIA AND
THE UKRAINE- THE END TO STOP THE
SPREAD OF DISINFORMATION ABOUT
THOSE EVENTS AS WELL- SEE MPA
STANDS IN SOLIDARITY WITH
UKRAINE WITH THE PEOPLE OF THE
CRANE AND HARD WORKING
JOURNALISTS. REPORTING ON THE
WAR ESPECIALLY THOSE ON THE
GROUND IN UKRAINE WHO ARE
RISKING THEIR LIVES. TO DELIVER
THE NEWS TICKETS WERE GETS TOO
NEEDS TO GO TO MOST- AND ON A
PERSONAL NOTE- A FRIEND OF MINE
HAS BEEN FROM UKRAINE AND SHE'S
BEEN UNABLE TO. TALK TO THE
MEDIA BECAUSE OF FEAR OF THEIR
FAMILIES BEING RETALIATED
AGAINST BY RUSSIAN SOLDIERS. AND
A THIRD OF IT YOU KNOW ONE SUCH
PERSON WHO SPOKE OUT TO THE B.
HAS HAD THEIR FAMILIES ARRESTED.
AND DETAINED AND SO WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR I. ABOUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
PRECIADO- ANYONE ELSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IF SO PLEASE
COME FORWARD. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS JOSEPH KERNAN ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA AND MY FAMILY LIVING
IN THE UKRAINE- SO. I WANT TO
GIVE MY SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
AND- AS THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE TO HELP. STOP
IMPORTING MILLIONS OF RUSSIAN
CRUDE OIL. YES TO YOUTH SOCCER
IN THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. I GET
AFTERNOON KATHERINE BRANDENBURG
ON BEHALF OF CINEMA CLEAN POWER
WE'RE ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE THE
ONE ALSO IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
EXPRESS THE SUPPORT POSITION.
OBSCENE NO ONE ELSE COME FORWARD
WILL GO TO THE MODERATOR ASKED
MODERATOR TO- ASSET QUESTION- ON
THE PHONE LINE IS OR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO. TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF. THE
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN CHECK.
THANKS FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
PERSECUTOR CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY IS THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE HELLO AND- MONICA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE EX. MUCH BETTER
THANKS AND I'M FORTY AND IN
ORDER THIS WILL AMOUNT TO HALF
OF THE ALL OF THE L. G. B. T. Q.
THE DEFENSE BUT THE EVIDENCE
WILL. PRESSURE AND- THE CRIME
THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK MODERATOR-
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS- WILL KNOW THAT
THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS IDENTIFIED SO ANYONE IN
THE ROOM IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. PLEASE COME FORWARD IF
SO. OBSCENE NO ONE COME FORWARD
WE'LL GO BACK TO THE MODERATOR
NESS MODERATOR TO IDENTIFY ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE LINE. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU-WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF
SB. FIFTEEN TWENTY EIGHT. MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT CAN YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK MODERATOR AND WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
NOW FOR ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR NEWMAN. AND
THANK YOU MR DEADSPIN REGARDED
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS DOG
PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR- AT I'VE
HAD SOME CONVERSATIONS WITH-
REPRESENTED FROM THE
PHARMACEUTICAL. INDUSTRY AND I'M
SURE YOU ALSO HAVE THEY HAVE-
ASK FOR AMENDMENTS- FOR SOME
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ALLOW
COMPANIES THAT ARE DOING
BUSINESS PARTICULAR CLINICAL
TRIALS- IN RUSSIA- THE
FLEXIBILITY TO WIND DOWN THOSE
OPERATIONS IN SOME WAY THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH BOTH FEDERAL
POLICY AND- YOU KNOW NO. SO I
JUST TO TOUCH THAT AND SEE WHAT
YOUR THOUGHTS ARE THERE BUT
OTHERWISE- GLAD TO SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ANYONE- WE HAVE HAD ONE
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION- THAT I
KNOW OF WITH. ONE PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANY- WE ASKED SOME QUESTIONS
AND THEY SAID THAT THEY'RE GONNA
BE GETTING BACK TO US. AND HAPPY
TO CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT. APPRECIATE.
THAT THANK YOU AND GOOD GLAD TO
MOVE THE BILL IN THE TWO. PROBE
VERY GOOD THANK ANYONE ELSE SO
WISHED. WE RECOGNIZE ON THE
DAIS. C. NONE IN CENTER NEW HAS
MADE A MOTION BUT BEFORE WE GO
THE MOTION ON A- TO CLOSE SO
CONSIDER RESPECT ASTRONOMICAL.
SO MORE GOOD FOR THE CALL AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST AMEND AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE. ON A
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION.
COURTESY HI COURTESY I OR
TROUBLE. THE TROUBLE I WRESTLE.
RUSSELL HI LAYERED HI THERE I
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN I. ALL
RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE THANK YOU GUYS SO
MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT BILL- THEN
THIS- SENATE RESOLUTION JOINT
RESOLUTION ELEVEN HAS TO BE
PRESENTED BY SENATOR SKINNER'S
CENTER HERE IF NOT- WE WILL PASS
AND COME BACK TO SENATOR
SKINNER- NEXT BILL IS. SB EIGHT
FIFTY CENTER WHERE THAT. WAS
ALREADY PASSED ON CONSENT
ACTUALLY THE NEXT ONE IN ORDER-
AND THEIR AFTER US SENATOR TO
ROSS ON S. B. TEN FORTY FOUR-
SENATOR ALSO IF YOU'RE- GOING TO
HEAR ON THE PHONE- YOU'RE YOU'RE
ALLOWED TO PRESENT FROM YEARS
BUT STILL UNDERCOVER PROTOCOL
BUT WHEREVER YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
IS FINE. SO AND I SKIPPED THE SP
NINE FIFTY ONE AM INTENTIONALLY
WAS AN ACUTE BOTTOM MY NOSE-
CENTER SKINNER WE- WILL PAUSE.
THANK YOU IN A DAY A DAY OF
FOLKS WALKING IN- JUST IN TIME
SENATOR SKINNER IF YOU'RE
PREPARED- YOU MAY PRESENT ON
YOUR RESOLUTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- YES
J. R. ELEVEN HE ASKED CONGRESS
TO PASS HR FIVE SEVEN TWO THREE
BY LARSEN AND THE REASON IS
BECAUSE SOCIAL SECURITY NEEDS TO
HAVE ITS FISCAL HEALTH OF UP
READ IT. WE HAVE MANY MANY
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE CALIFORNIA
THROUGHOUT THE US WHO. HI MERRY
SOURCE OF INCOME IS SOCIAL
SECURITY WHETHER THEY'RE SENIORS
VETERANS WOMEN CHILDREN THOSE
LIVING WITH DISABILITY. AND THE
CURRENT FISCAL HEALTH OF OUR
SOCIAL SECURITY SYSTEM. COULD BE
GREATLY IMPROVED BY TWENTY
THIRTY FOUR. IT IS PROJECTED THE
BENEFICIARIES MAY RECEIVE ONLY
78% OF THEIR FULL BENEFITS
THROUGH HR FIVE SEVEN THREE.
WOULD PROVIDE MORE FUNDS AND CUT
THE FUTURE SOCIAL SECURITY
DEFICIT AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO
SOCIAL SECURITY SO LET ME CALL
ON MY- WITNESSES FOR THEIR
TESTIMONY I HAVE NANCY ALTMAN
THE PRESIDENT OF SOCIAL SECURITY
WORKS AND PAULINE BROOKS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
RETIRED AMERICANS. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER AT NANCY ALTMAN
I CARED TO STRENGTHEN SOCIAL
SECURITY COALITION A BROAD BASED
ALLIANCE OF OVER THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY. NATIONAL AND STATE
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING
FIFTEEN MILLION AMERICANS.
COALITION STRONGLY ENDORSES.
THIS BILL AND THIS RESOLUTION
BECAUSE THE BILL WILL GREATLY
IMPROVE THE ECONOMIC SECURITY OF
CALIFORNIANS AND INDEED ALL
AMERICANS THE LEGISLATION TO
EXPAND SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS
ACROSS THE BOARD AND THEN
TARGETED WAYS AND PAYS FOR IT BY
REQUIRING THE WEALTHIEST TO
CONTRIBUTE AT THE SAME RATE AS
THE REST OF US. EXPANDING SOCIAL
SECURITY IS KEY TO ADDRESSING
THE NATION'S RETIREMENT INCOME
CRISIS AND THE SQUEEZE ON
WORKING FAMILIES. THE MODEST
BENEFITS ARE PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT TO VETERANS AS WELL AS
WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AND OTHERS WILL PAY
FOR EXTERMINATION REQUIRING BOTH
THE TOP TO CONTRIBUTE MORE IS
KEY TO ADDRESSING INCOME
INEQUALITY. THE LEGISLATION WILL
STRENGTHEN THE ECONOMY AND
CREATE JOBS FOR THE INFORMATION
OF MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE I
PREPARED A CHART WHICH I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE IN YOUR MATERIALS WHICH
SHOWS THE NUMBER OF
BENEFICIARIES AS WELL AS THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF SOCIAL
SECURITY DOLLARS THE FLOW
MONTHLY. TO THE COUNTIES IN YOUR
DISTRICT. IMPORTANT ESTE ALLOWED
CALL FROM HIGH TO BE ON THE
CRUCIAL LEGISLATION. ADULT IS
CENTRAL TO BEGINNING TO RESTORE
THE INTANGIBLE BUT INVALUABLE
BENEFITS SECURITY PEACE OF MIND
WHICH TOO MANY AMERICANS HAVE
LOST BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
ACTION- AFTER POLL REVEALS THAT
AMERICANS OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORT
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL BUT
BECAUSE CONGRESS HAS NOT VOTED.
AMERICANS WERE UNCLEAR WITH
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS STANDS.
MOREOVER ONLY A VOTE WILL
PROVIDE THE NEEDED IMMEDIATE
ATTENTION FOR ALL THESE REASONS
I HOPE YOU CAN VOTE IN FAVOR OF
THE JOINT RESOLUTION AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE THANK YOU- THANK YOU-
THE- THE NEXT WITNESS- IS HAS
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS POLLING
BROOKS. POINT ONLINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. YES MY NAME IS LAURA
AND I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF RETIRED
AMERICAN. CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
GRASSROOTS SENIOR ADVOCACY
DEPARTMENT THANK. FINE SIR
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION ELEVEN
AND WE URGE YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT IT TODAY. I REPRESENT
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS OF MY
GENERATION SEVENTY PLUS. MY
GENDER A WOMAN IN MY COMMUNITY A
PERSON OF COLOR WHO WORK IN
PRIVATE SECTOR NONPROFIT IN
OTHER INDUSTRIES THAT DID NOT
HAVE PENSION PLANS. THEREFORE
SOCIAL SECURITY MY RETIREMENT I
STRUGGLE EACH MONTH TO PAY MY
EXPENSES INCLUDING MY HEALTH
CARE WHICH SEEMS TO GO UP EVERY
TIME THERE'S A DEGREE. IN SOCIAL
SECURITY COLA. MEDICARE PREMIUMS
ALSO INCREASED LIKE THE 14%
INCREASE THIS YEAR. SOCIAL
SECURITY IS A LIFESAVER FOR
PEOPLE LIKE ME IN FACT TWO
THIRDS OF SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFICIARIES HAVE NO OTHER
SOURCE OF RETIREMENT INCOME. H.
R. FIVE SEVEN TWO THREE THE
SOCIAL SECURITY TWENTY ONE UNDER
ACT WOULD FIX MANY PROBLEMS AND
EQUITIES AND THE SOCIAL SECURITY
SYSTEM BUT ONE IT WOULD INCREASE
THE BASE GRANTS ANY ANNUAL COLA
. AND BASED THESE INCREASES ON
THE ELDER ECONOMIC INDEX WHICH
IS A MUCH MORE REALISTIC OUR
SYSTEM OF THE COST OF LIVING FOR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. H. R. FIVE SEVEN
TWO THREE WILL IT MAKE IT EASIER
FOR BENEFICIARIES THE PILE BUT
EARNED BENEFITS. AND IT WILL
BETTER STAFF THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION. IT REPEALED THE
HORRENDOUS WINDFALL EXEMPTION
PROVISION AND GOVERNMENT PENSION
OFFSET WHICH DRAWS THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE FROM THE SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS THAT THEY HAVE EARNED.
AND IT PAYS FOR ALL OF THIS.
PLUS FUN THE SOCIAL SECURITY
TRUST FUND FOR DECADES BY ASKING
THE MOST WEALTHY AMONG THAT THE
JUDGE PAID THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
BIKE ATTACKED. CALIFORNIA MOSCOW
ON RECORD IN SUPPORT OF HR FIVE
SEVEN TWO THREE AND URGE YOUR
CONVENTIONAL DELEGATES TO VOTE
FOR THIS LEGISLATION. YOUR
PASSAGE OF SJR ELEVEN WILL LEAD
THE WAY FOR OTHER STATES TO PASS
SIMILAR RESOLUTIONS AND SEVEN
DAYS VERY STRONG MESSAGE TO
CONVERT BUT THE TIME IS NOW. TO
PROTECT- EXPANDS SECURITY BUT
EVERYONE IT ALLOWS ME TO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT BY CELL IN
THE YEARS TO COME IT WILL ENSURE
BENEFITS FOR OUR CHILDREN.
GRANDCHILDREN AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY- WILL COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM AND ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT THIS J. R. LEVIN.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS JENNA SO MAINLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. I WAS COMBINED GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DUANE CAMP AT
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
RETIRED AMERICANS PROUD SPONSOR
OF THIS RESOLUTION INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE AUTHOR ON HER
LEADERSHIP AND HUMBLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO TAKE A SUPPORT
POSITION THE SCENE NONE WE WILL
MOVE TO THE MODERATOR ASKED THE
MODERATOR. TO QUEUE UP ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. J. R.
ELEVEN. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT. THEY ARE ELEVEN MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NINE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR THE SISTER BRAMBLE CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
PROCESSING OUR SUPPORT POSITION
. NINE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MISTER
KAREN NUMBERS CORRESPOND WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF G. J.
R. ELEVEN THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR SHARE MY
CAROL WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WE ARE ALSO
SUPPORTING THAT THERE ARE ELEVEN
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
MCCOURT. LINE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK SEVENTEEN YOU MAY BE
UNUSUAL YEAH I HAD THIS ISSUE.
HI THIS IS KEITH AMADO MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- I'M A MEMBER OF
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE AND ON MARCH TWELFTH
THE DNC BATH. IT'S SIMILAR
RESOLUTION TO ASK CONGRESS TO
VOTE PASSED SOCIAL SECURITY
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED AFTER. A
SACRED TRUST. ONE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BRANDI JACKSON CALIFORNIA
BUILDER RIGHT STRONG SUPPORT.
ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM THIRTY TWO
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU I'M MY
NAME'S KAREN **** I'M A MEMBER
OF. KAREN CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
FOR RETIRED AMERICANS AND- ADULT
SCHOOL TEACHERS UNITED IN
RICHMOND AND- I'M STRONGLY IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL. I'M A
TEACHER WHO IS AFFECTED WILL BE
DIRECTLY AFFECTED BY THE PASSAGE
AND I'M HAPPY THAT YOU'RE DOING
THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU. AND
ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE ONE
FURTHER LINE IN Q.
ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THIRTY
NINE. CARL. AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER PLANS IN Q. THANK YOU
MUCH THANK YOU MODERATOR- THERE
IS- NOT LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
IDENTIFIED AS OR ANYONE HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WANTS TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SO PLEASE
COMPORT. TWENTY NINE I'M GONNA
GO BACK TO THE MODERATOR IN ASK
YOU TO KINDLY CHECK THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF S. J.
R. ELEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH I'M IN A
POSITION THAT THEY ARE ELEVEN.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO LINES IN OPPOSITION
. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AGAIN
MODERATOR- WE WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT IN
TIME- ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I WOULD MOVE THE
RESOLUTION OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR WHICH WE WILL TAKE
UP ONCE WE GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO- SENATOR SKINNER TOO CLOSE
THANKS SO MUCH I THINK READ THE-
EXPERT SPOKE TO IT I THINK THE
KEY THING TO NOTE. THAT WAS
REFERENCED BUT NOT SPELLED OUT
IS THAT THERE IS A CAP WAS PUT
ON WAGE EARNERS OF A HUNDRED AND
BETWEEN A HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND WHERE THE WAGE EARNER
AT FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND IN
FACT. SAME PICA AS A HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO THOUSAND WAGE EARNER
AND THAT IF WE JUST FIX THAT
WHICH OF COURSE S. J. R. LEVIN
OUR ROUTE THROUGH THE BUILD THAT
STR ELEVEN. WORDING WOULD DO YOU
WOULD FIX THAT THEN WE COULD
ADDRESS THE SHORTFALL. AND I
THINK MANY- MANY LEGISLATORS- OF
COURSE HAVE THIS ON YOUR MIND
SINCE WE DO NOT GET PENSIONS
THEN THERE MAY BE A GOOD NUMBER
OF US WHO WILL BE. LIKE OVER.
OVER SIXTY FIVE MILLION
AMERICANS POTENTIALLY LIVING ON
SOCIAL SECURITY ALONE. WITHOUT
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. WHO DO YOU
THINK YOU CONSIDER SKINNER IN
THE- WE WILL MOVE ON TO. THE
CONSULTANT ON THE MOTION BY
SENATOR LAYERED IN THE HOUSE OF
THE CONSOLE IN THE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS THAT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED COURTESY
ALL RIGHT COURTESY I OR TROUBLE. THE TROUBLE NO VOTING THE
RUSSELL. THE REST SO I LAYERED
HI THERE TO FIND HUMAN. NEWMAN
HI THE THAT ITEM IS OUT ON A
FOUR TO ONE VOTE. FOUR ZERO FOUR
ZERO I'M SORRY WE HAD NO
OPPOSITION THERE WAS. FOUR
AFFIRMATIVE VOTES THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER THE NEXT WE HAVE
CENTER DRAWS SO I'M PRESENTING
SP NINETY ONE AND SHE WILL FALL
WITH TWO OTHER BILLS BUT WILL
CALL THOSE IN DUE COURSE AND- AS
I START TO SAY EARLIER YOU'RE
MORE THAN WELCOME 2% FROM HERE
UNDER THE CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCES.
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU MR CHAIR
R. AND MEMBERS OF SP NINE FIVE
ONE WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
WORKERS CAN AFFORD TO TAKE THE
TIME OFF TO CARE FOR SERIOUSLY
ILL FAMILY MEMBER. BOND WITH A
NEW CHILD OR RECOVER FROM THEIR
OWN SERIOUS ILLNESS BY
INCREASING THE WAGE
REPLENISHMENT REPLACEMENT RATES.
WERE THE LOWEST WAGE WORKERS
WHEN THEY USE STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE OR PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
ALMOST ALL PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA
CONTRIBUTE TO THE DISABILITY
INSURANCE FUND WHICH PROVIDES
WAGE REPLACEMENT FOR WORKERS
THROUGH THE STI AND- THE PFL
PROGRAMS HOWEVER. MIDDLE AND
HIGH WAGE WORKERS ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO USE THESE BENEFITS
THAN LOW WAGE WORKERS THIS MEANS
LOW WAGE WORKERS ARE ESSENTIALLY
SUBSIDIZING BELIEVE OF HIGHER
WAGE WORKERS. WHEN WORKERS ARE
ASKED ABOUT WHY THEY DO NOT
UTILIZE THE FAMILY AND MEDICAL
LEAVE THEY'RE ENTITLED TO THEY
GIVE TWO REASONS THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT LOST WAGES ONE ANDTWO
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT LOSING
THEIR JOBS. WELL IN RECENT YEARS
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED
JOB PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS OUT
ON FAMILY MEDICAL LEAVE WE HAVE
MADE LITTLE PROGRESS IN
ADDRESSING LOST INCOME. TO
ADDRESS THAT CONCERN. AS B. NINE
FIFTY ONE PROPOSES TO PHASE IN A
90% WAGE REPLACEMENT FOR WORKERS
WHO EARN LESS THAN 70 F THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE WEEKLY WAGE.
UP VOTE NINETY. AND IT WOULD BE
FOR UP TO SIXTEEN WEEKS OF
DISABILITY INSURANCE AND UP TO
EIGHT WEEKS OF PAID FAMILY LEAVE
ALL OTHER WORKERS. OF THOSE
ABOVE 70% ALL WOULD RECEIVE 70%
WAGE REPLACEMENT. UP TO THE
MAXIMUM WEEKLY BENEFIT. TO
ACHIEVE THIS AS B. NINE FIFTY
ONE SIMPLY REMOVES THE TAXABLE
WAGE CEILING. ENSURING ALL
WORKERS CONTRIBUTE AN EQUAL
PERCENTAGE WHICH IS CAPPED AT
ONE POINT 5% OF THEIR WAGE
INCOME INTO THE STI FUND.
WORKERS CURRENTLY EARNING LESS
THAN A HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WOULD PAY NO
MORE THAN THEY DO CURRENTLY. NO
ONE SHOULD HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN PUTTING FOOD ON THE
TABLE AND TAKING THE TIME THEY
NEED TO CARE FOR SERIOUSLY ILL
FAMILY MEMBER BOND WITH A NEW
CHILD OR RECOVER FROM THEIR OWN
ILL ILLNESS. TODAY I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES MISTER CHAIR HERE TO
PRESENT AS B. NINE FIVE ONE
CATHERINE WITH CHET- STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR LEGAL AID AT WORK.
AND JERRY SANDOVAL MARY PARENT.
OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO- WE
WILL CALL THE LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES AT THIS TIME AND I'M
NOT SURE WHICH ORDER THEY'RE
GOING TO SPEAK AND SO I WILL
CALL THEM IN THE ORDER YOU JUST
INDICATED- SENATOR CATHERINE-
CAPTAIN WHICH YET- ARE YOU. ON
THE TELECONFERENCE ON YES OKAY
VERY PLEASED WITH RECEIVING AN
AREA THANK YOU. OKAY GREAT- HI
EVERYONE MY NAME IS KATHERINE
WHICH ADMINISTAFF ATTORNEY AT
LEGAL AID AT WORK WHICH IS A
CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT DEDICATED
TO ADVANCING THE RIGHTS OF
WORKERS WITH LOW WAGES. AND
WEAK. AND STRONG RECORD OF AT
NINE FIVE ONE BECAUSE HE HAD
FAMILY LEAVE AND STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE ARE
CRITICAL TO THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA FAMILY. LEAVE
PROGRAMS PROVIDE INCOME WHEN
WORKERS ARE UNABLE TO WORK
BECAUSE OF THEIR OWN HEALTH
CONDITIONS OR THE NEED TO BRING
A FAMILY MEMBER ON CONDITION
ADULT. AND RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
ACCESS TO THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDE
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR WORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND EVEN HAVE
LONG. TERM IMPACT ON CHILD TO
DEVELOP. IMPORTANTLY THE FROM
ARE FOR IT WE SIMPLY BY WORKERS
AVAILABLE UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS.
BUT CURRENTLY PAID FAMILY LEAVE
AND- SO THE INSURANCE ONLY PAYS
MOST WORKERS 60% OF THEIR INCOME
. THE MINIMUM WAGE WORKERS WHO
MAY VERY LIKELY ALREADY BE
STRUGGLING TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILY WILL ONLY RECEIVE ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER WEEK FROM STI
WORKING FAMILY LEAVE. AND IF
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR THEM TO
LIVE ON THAT MAY HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN FALLING DEEPER INTO DEBT
OR SIMPLY GOING BACK TO WORK FOR
A DAY FOR YOUR FAMILY NUMBER ARE
READY. AND WE KNOW FROM OUR WORK
IN THE COMMUNITY THAT THESE
INADEQUATE BRAKES PREVENT
FATHERS FROM TAKING BONDING TIME
THEY FORCED NEW PARENTS BACK TO
WORK WHILE THEY'RE STILL
RECOVERING FROM CHILDBIRTH AND
IT PREVENTS ADULT CHILDREN FROM
BEING ABLE TO BE THERE FOR THEIR
AGING PARENTS. AND THIS IS BORNE
OUT IN THE DATA RIGHT NOW FOLKS
EARNING UNDER TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR MAKE UP 37% OF
THOSE WHO ARE CONTRIBUTING TO
THE FUND BUT ONLY 14% OF THOSE
WHO USE PAID FAMILY LEAVE. AND
ONLY 18% OF. THOSE WHO MAKE THE
I. CLAIMS. AT THE NINE FIVE ONE
WOULD FIX THIS BECAUSE I 9% OF
REGULAR INCOME THE LOW WAGE
WORKERS TO APPLY FOR THESE
PROGRAMS. IT WOULD BE AVAILABLE
FOR EIGHT WEEKS OF PAID FAMILY
LEAVE AND TWICE AS LONG FOR SBI.
SIXTEEN WEEKS. WHICH IS THE
AVERAGE LENGTH OF ALL S. YEAH I
THINK YOU LOOK GREAT IT WOULD
MAKE THE MOST. ATHLETIC PROGRAM
IN THE COUNTRY. THE PAPER THE
IMPROVEMENTS WHILE PROTECTING
THE D. I. FUNDS WHICH SUPPLIES
THESE PROGRAMS DEVELOP IMPLEMENT
THESE CHANGES. OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS WITH SIMPLY DELETE AN
EXEMPTION THAT CURRENTLY
SHELTERS INCOME. ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE. THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FROM BEING SUBJECT TO
CONTRIBUTION. WITHOUT THESE
CHANGES BOTH STI IN PFL WILL
REMAIN OUT OF REACH FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED THE MOST.
RECENT. OUT HERE I THOUGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TEST. IN
THE WE'RE GOING TO CALL- NOW ON. TERRY YOUR REASONABLE NEARY.
THANK YOU VERY YES YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU PLEASE PROCEED TO THE
TORIA IT STARTED OFF-
MISPRONOUNCING YOUR NAME TERRY.
NO WORRIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY YES MY NAME
IS GERRY SAMPLE I BELIEVE IN SAN
DIEGO AND I'M A PROUD MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COLLISION. AND VANDALISM I AM
IDENTIFIED TODAY'S FRONT SUPPORT
OF AS THE NINE FIFTY ONE. WHEN
MY DAUGHTER WAS BORN I DIDN'T
KNOW I HAD THE RIGHT TO TAKE
PAID FAMILY LEAVE OUT THE MALE
PARENT UNTIL SOMEBODY TOLD ME
THAT I COULD. MEANT THE WORLD TO
ME. THANK GOD MY NEWBORN. HAVE A
LOOK FIRST ENCOUNTERS WITH-
HELPING AROUND THE HOUSE. REALLY
HAPPY MY DAUGHTER CHANGED MY
LIFE. I HAD THROUGHOUT THE WEEK
WITH HER. BUT WHEN I GOT MY
FIRST BASICALLY ET. I REALIZED I
COULDN'T AFFORD TO STAY ON PAID
FAMILY LEAVE AND PAY MY BILL. IT
WAS HEARTBREAKING BUT I REALIZED
THAT I HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO
RETURN BACK TO WORK. I WORK TWO
JOBS A GREATER SHIFT IN ANOTHER
JOB AGAIN IN THE MORNING. I
WOULD ONLY FIFTY FOUR HOURS A
NIGHT I WOULD DECIDE TO GET HOME
AFTER WORK AND TELL MY KID A
LOVER. AND STILL TRY TO HELP OUT
AROUND THE HOUSE. I THINK THAT
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO CAN AFFORD
TO TAKE PAID FAMILY LEAVE ARE
THE ONES. WHO MAKE ENOUGH MONEY
TO SAVE MONEY. WHEN YOU LIVE
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK LIKE I DID.
NOT FIT INTO YOUR BANK ACCOUNT.
BUT YOU CAN YOU CAN 76% WHICH
WOULD LIKE. TO PUT PEOPLE IN A
SITUATION LIKE THE ONE THE
LECTURE IS ALEXANDER. WHERE THEY
CAN'T- THEY CAN'T HAPPEN THAT
MAKE SOME DECISIONS. LIKE
WHETHER IT WILL WORK OR STAY
HOME. WITH THE BABY OR TAKE CARE
OF A FAMILY MEMBER WITH ST. ONLY
VERY IMPORTANT AND THAT THE MALE
PERSON I WANT TO BE ABLE TO WORK
MY FAMILY. AND I WANT THE BEST
MY CHILD. I MAKE A LOT OF
SACRIFICES FOR MY FAMILY. AT THE
END OF THE DAY FAMILIES WHO IS
THERE FOR YOU. I FEEL LIKE- I
DID SERVE TO TAKE A LEAVE WHEN I
NEED TO. PURCHASE THE PROGRAM
BUT I'M PAYING INTO. THE ONLY
WAY I WOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE IS THAT IF THE WAGE
REPLACEMENT RATE IS INCREASED TO
NINETY PERCENT. I KNOW I SPEAK
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY WHO ARE LIKE ME.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON SB NINETY ONE
TODAY. THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- WE WILL NOW
MOVE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM
AND- ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE
WHO WISHES TO. EXPRESS THE
SUPPORT POSITION WELCOME. RATHER
INTERGRAPH REMEMBERS. I'M AJ
LUCAS AND ON BEHALF OF UNITED
WAY. AND CO SPONSOR THE BILL WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE ANYONE ELSE WISH TO
EXPRESS THE SUPPORT POSITION IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM. OBSCENE NO
ONE A STAND UP WE WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR ASKED THE MODERATOR.
BUT PLEASE CHECK FOR SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON THE COASTLINE.
THANK YOU MR. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF FIFTY NINE THE ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FIFTY ONE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN THERE. NINE SEVENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE MY NAME IS
BEYOND CRIME POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
A SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY
ADVOCATE FOR SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS IN THE STATE AND WE ARE
CALLING AND GROUND REPORT AT
NINE FIFTY ONE AS I HELP MY
BUSINESS OWNERS. THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTER NAMED
REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WANT TO GET IN THERE ON BEHALF
OF EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND
THE CHARM HEALTH WE ADVOCATES
NETWORK AND TRANSPORT THANK YOU
. NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. KAREN
NUMBERS MARICO YOSHIHARA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS. FOR IT YOUR
- NINE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT THE END
OF THE CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THAT
USUALLY ARE WHITE. NINE EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS YOU KNOW WHY THE WHOLE WALL
IS NOT P. HELLO FORMULA
REPRESENTING A THREE POINT THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS YEAH OF
COURSE OF A PRE NINE FIFTY ONE.
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FIVE ONE THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS- DONNA INTO
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA CAREGIVER RESOURCE
CENTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FIFTY ONE FOR OUR FAMILY
CARE GIVERS AND THOSE OLDER.
ADULTS THAT THEY ARE KERRY.
WORKING WITH A LOT OF WORKING
HERE THANK YOU. NINE NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBERS CRITICAL ON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INSTRUCT THE
COURT THANK YOU. NINE FORTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAPPING DOWN
OFTEN REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG WORK. NINE
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS ONLY MCKAY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA AT FIRST FIVE LA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. NINE NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS MOLLY SHEEHAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FIFTY ONE THANK YOU ALL. NINE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
CLARK WITH CHILDREN NOW IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE WATER SMITH CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY COALITION A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB NINE FIFTY ONE AND
ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF OF NARAL
PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA WHO IS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIFTY
ONE. THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU HAVE TO CALIFORNIA TO
DISABILITY RIGHT FROM WORK I
ALSO BUT CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
RETIRED AMERICANS THANK YOU FOR
. NINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS MALCOLM HARRIS AND I'M-
CAMPAIGN MANAGER FOR CALIFORNIA
USC WEST CATHOLIC TEARING ACROSS
GENERATIONS AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIFTY ONE.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
ARE YOU DONE THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WE WILL COME UP BACK
NOW TO LEAD OPPOSITION WE HAVE
NO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
IDENTIFIED ON THIS BILL WE WILL
ASK NOW IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WISHES TO EXPRESS
AN OPPOSED POSITION ON THIS BILL
SO PLEASE. STAND COME FORWARD-
SEEN NONE OF BACK TO THE
MODERATOR MODERATOR. PLEASE
CHECK TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
COASTLINE. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF
SB NINE FIFTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. AT THIS TIME. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN A POSITION OF
SB NINE FIFTY ONE MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I WAS
TRYING TO CALL IN SUPPORT BUT I
GOT DISCONNECTED MY NAME'S
FELICITY FIGUEROA I'M WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY QUALITY COALITION
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB NINE FIVE ONE. THANK YOU.
FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS TOM RANKIN I'M VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA ONCE RETIRED
AMERICANS AND IN CONTRADICTION
TO RANDY HICKS OUR POSITION IS
OFFICIALLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. NORMALLY WE WOULD BE
ALL IN FAVOR OF THIS THEY ALSO
WERE ABLE 290% HAVE TO CONCLUDE
WELL THIS IS A LINE SIMPLY FOR
IDENTIFICATION SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN THIS CASE OPTICAL.
ASSIGNMENT I AM IN OFFICE RIGHT
NOW AND IN OPPOSITION WE HEARD
YOU LOUD AND. CLEAR AND IT'S ON
THE RECORD AND THANK YOU FOR
CALLING IN. LOTTERY CAN THEN
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU THE STRUCTURE AND LIKE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ONE ZERO FIVE I'M SORRY I WAS
ACTUALLY CALLING IN SUPPORT BUT
HE DIDN'T GET MY NUMBER IN
QUICKLY ENOUGH I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC COUNCIL- AND-
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB NINE
FIFTY ONE AND URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES. THERE IS NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION OF FIFTY
NINE PEOPLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE APPRECIATE ALL THE- CALLERS-
IN AGAIN- WE ESTABLISH THE IT
THE OUTSET AND I'M ONLY SAYING
THIS BECAUSE YOU HAVE A COUPLE
MORE BILLS- THREE IN FACT TO BE
HEARD TODAY- WE APPRECIATE
EVERYONE KEEPING THEIR LEAD
TESTIMONY TO TWO MINUTES- WE
HAVE- WITH ITS OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT AND WEATHER'S OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT IDENTIFICATION-
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION. ON
THE APPROPRIATE LINE EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION SO TRY TO
BE MORE CLEAR IN CALLING THOSE
OUT AS WE MOVE ALONG- I MIGHT BE
GETTING A LITTLE RELAX APPEAR
BUT- WE'LL KEEP AT IT- THANK YOU
AND- WE ARE NOW GOING TO COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR.
SUBSTANTIVE COMMENTS BY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE OF ANY OR
QUESTIONS. AGAIN THIS IS SONYA
SP NINE FIFTY ONE- MATURE HAVE
REMOVED BILL WHEN SUCH A TIME AS
APPROPRIATE. OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION- READY TO GO SENATOR ALSO
YOU DO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE IF YOU LIKE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I BOTH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WILL MOVE TO THE
CONSOLE NOW AND ASKS FOR A ROLL
CALL VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY ALL RIGHT. COURTESY I
OR TWO AGO. THE TROUBLE NO DRESS
ALL THE REST SO I LAYERED HI
LARRY I NEWMAN. NEWMAN I ALL
RIGHT SO THAT BILL IS OUT FOR
THE ONE ON CINDER NEWMAN'S
MOTION THANK YOU. ON WHEN A
PAUSE FOR A MINUTE BEFORE YOU
MOVE ON SP A TEN FORTY FOUR
WHICH IS ALSO CENTERED ROSES
BILL IN- ASK- CONSULTANTS- TO
LIFT THE CALL I THINK THERE'S
ONE PREVIOUS BILL WHERE WE HAD
TEMPORARY A COUPLE ABSENT
MEMBERS PRESENTING ELSEWHERE WE
CAN DEAL WITH THAT RIGHT NOW
IT'LL SAVE ME FROM REMEMBERING.
TO DO IT LATER THANK YOU. S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE FIRST REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BILL RUSSELL HI THE REST OF I
LAYERED HI LARRY I. THAT'S FORTY
ONE ALL RIGHT GOOD SO THAT BILL
IS OUT NOW ON A FOUR TO ONE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NO WILL
GIVE BACK TO- OR ORDINARY
KITCHEN THE SEQUENCE HERE THE
NEXT BILL IN ORDER IS S. B. TEN
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR DRAWS A
SENDER. IF YOU'RE PREPARED YOU
MAY PRESENT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES SP TEN
FORTY FOUR IS A BILL THAT WILL
ALLOW WORKERS. TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THEIR MOBILE PHONES OR OTHER
COMMUNICATION DEVICES AS WELL
AS- BE ALLOWED TO LEAVE THE
WORKPLACE. FOR THEIR SAFETY IN
THE EVENT OF A STATE OR
EMERGENCY OR EMERGENCY
CONDITION. BEFORE MOVING AHEAD I
WANT TO INDICATE I'M ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AND I
THANK THE CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE
STAFF WERE WORKING WITH US THE
CLEAR FIGHT WHEN WE NEED THIS
PROTECTION IN PLACE. AND THAT IT
IS A TEMPORARY PROTECTION HI TO
THE EXISTENCE OF EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS. IN ADDITION
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS REQUIRE AN
EMPLOYEE TO NOTIFY THE EMPLOYER
BEFORE LEAVING THE PREMISES DUE
TO EMERGENCY CONDITIONS IF IT
CAN BE DONE SAFELY. WORKER
SAFETY IS A BASIC PROTECTION WE
STRIVE TO PROVIDE ALL
CALIFORNIANS. UNFORTUNATELY
THERE HAVE BEEN CASES OF WORKERS
BEING PUT IN VULNERABLE AND LIFE
AND DEATH SITUATIONS WHERE THEY
ARE REQUIRED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK. DESPITE THE IMMINENT
THREAT OF A STATE OR EMERGENCY
OR OTHER SIGNIFICANT EMERGENCY
CONDITION. IN CALIFORNIA
EXAMPLES OF DECLARED STATE OR
EMERGENCIES INCLUDING WILD FIRES
EARTHQUAKES FLOODS AND MUDSLIDES
EMERGENCY CONDITIONS THAT ALSO
NEED TO BE ACCOUNTED FOR INCLUDE
MAN MADE EMERGENCIES SITUATIONS
INCLUDING MASS SHOOTINGS AND
TERROR EVENTS. FOR EXAMPLE THE
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE SEASON IS
NOW A YEAR LONG THREAT WITH NINE
OF THE LARGEST AND SEVEN OF THE
MOST DESTRUCTIVE FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY HAVING
OCCURRED IN THE LAST DECADE IN
THE MIDST OF THESE CATASTROPHIC
DISASTERS THERE ARE NUMEROUS
CASES OF WORKERS HAVING BEEN
REQUIRED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WORKING. AS FIRE APPROACHED THE
WORKPLACE AND THE OTHERS WERE
EVACUATED AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
INVENTOR AND CINEMA COUNTIES
WERE REQUIRED TO CONTINUE
PICKING PRODUCE DURING THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THOMAS AND THAT
LIST OF FIRES JUST A FEW MILES
FROM THE FIRE LINES WITH MINIMAL
CONSIDERATION FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES HEALTH AND SAFETY
WILDFIRES CONTINUE TO ROAR AND
THREATEN ENTIRE COMMUNITIES.
DURING THE TWENTY NINETEEN GETTY
FIRE LOS ANGELES COUNTY DOMESTIC
WORKERS AND LANDSCAPERS WERE
STILL REQUIRED TO REPORT TO WORK
IN THE EVACUATED HILL PROPERTIES
AS THE THREAD OF THE FIRE LOOMED
AROUND THEM- A SIMILAR INCIDENTS
HAVE OCCURRED IN AMAZON
WAREHOUSES AND DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS. WHERE WORKERS ARE BEING
PLACED IN DANGEROUS SITUATIONS
IN THE MIDST OF EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS THESE INCIDENTS MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO SET
CLEAR STANDARDS TO KEEP WORKERS
SAFE IN REAL TIME DURING THESE
EVENTS. AS B. TEN FORTY FOUR
WOULD ENHANCE EXISTING WORKER
PROTECTIONS DURING NATURAL
DISASTERS OR EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS BY PROVIDING CLEAR
REQUIREMENTS FOR EMPLOYERS TO
ALLOW WORKERS TO ACCESS PHONES
OR THE COMMUNICATIONS. AND BEING
PERMITTED TO LEAVE IF THEY DO SO
FOR THEIR SAFETY OR THAT OF
THEIR CHILDREN. OF THE
OPPOSITION HAS RAISED CONCERNS
SUCH AS THIS BILL IS NOT
INTENDED IT AND THESE ARE A
RESPONSE THIS BILL IS NOT
INTENDED TO LAST THROUGHOUT THE
DURATION OF A STATE OF EMERGENCY
IT APPLIES ONLY WHERE EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS EXIST AND AGAIN THIS
WAS INCLUDED IN THE COMMIT
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THIS BILL
IS NOT DUE CLICK TO DOES NOT
DUPLICATE EXISTING LAW- THERE
ARE NO SPECIFIC PROVISIONS
GOVERNING. AN EMPLOYER'S
OBLIGATIONS OR WORKERS RIGHT
DURING A STATE OF EMERGENCY OR
EMERGENCY CONDITIONS THIS IS NOT
THE SAME AS THE RIGHT TO REFUSE
UNSAFE WORK WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT UNSAFE WORK ASSIGNMENTS OR
AN UNSAFE JOB YOU DON'T GO-
HOLDING UP YOU KNOW SIXTY POUND
BOXES OR- OR GOING THROUGH A LOT
OF WIRES- WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
CONDITIONS OUTSIDE THE EMPLOYERS
CONTROL. THE MAKE THE WORKSITE
UNSAFE THIS IS NOT THE SAME AS
THE RIGHT TO REFUSE UNSAFE WORK
. WE UNDERSTAND MANY EMPLOYERS
ARE SEEKING EXEMPTIONS FOR
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES OPEN TO
TALKING ABOUT THIS HOW THIS
APPLIES TO WORKERS WHOSE JOB IT
IS TO RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES MY
STAFF STARTED THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. ARM AND WE INTEND
TO CONTINUE THEM THIS WEEK TO
SEE IF WE CAN HIT OF A BALANCE
COLLEAGUES WE HAVE CONTINUED TO
WITNESS THE DEVASTATING IMPACTS
THAT EMERGENCIES AND NATURAL
DISASTERS CONTINUE TO HAVE ON
OUR COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY ARE
VULNERABLE WORKERS. WE HAVE TO
RESPOND BY PROVIDING CLEAR
PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS AND
CLEAR RULES FOR EMPLOYERS TO
KEEP WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILY
SAFE WITH ME TODAY AS WITNESSES
ARE RON AT ATA PRESIDENT OF THE
LA COUNTY FEDERATION OF LABOR AS
WELL AS KARINA LOPEZ FORMER
AMAZON WORKER JUSTICE HAS TO
FIGHT AND SUPPORT. I ALSO HAVE
CAITLIN VEGA. WHO IS UP L. A.
FEDERATION OF LABOR OF WAS ON
THE LINE TO HELP WITH ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK SENATOR-
MR IF YOU'RE THERE- YOU MAY
PROCEED TO TESTIFY. IF YOU CARRY
MEMBERS HONORARY PRESIDENT OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR PROUD
SPONSOR OF SB TEN FORTY FOUR.
THE COUNTY FEDERATION REPRESENTS
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND UNION
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT GREATER LOS
ANGELES THE MAJORITY OF WHOM ARE
BLACK AND BROWN WORKERS. IT IS
OUR JOB TO MAINTAIN THE BASIC
PROTECTIONS WORKING PEOPLE HAVE
ALWAYS NEEDED BUT ALSO TO LOOK
AHEAD AT. EMERGING THREATS THAT
WORKERS FACE AS CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS OUR ENVIRONMENT IT ALSO
IMPACTS OUR WORK SITE IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS I'VE SEEN MORE
FIRES THREATEN WORKERS ON THE
JOB THAN I DID. IN ALL THE
PREVIOUS DECADES IN LA COUNTY
ALONE WE'VE HAD WILDFIRES
FLOODING MUDSLIDES IN EXTREME
HEAT STATE LAW MUST NOW KEEP UP
TO ENSURE WORKERS ARE PROTECTED
DURING EMERGENCIES AND NATURAL
DISASTERS. JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO
WE ALL HEARD THE STORIES OF
AMAZON WAREHOUSE WORKERS AND
DRIVERS IN ILLINOIS' WHO WERE
NOT PERMITTED TO LEAVE DURING A
TORNADO SADLY. SIX AMAZON
WORKERS AND SEVERAL OTHER
FACTORY WORKERS WERE KILLED
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT
PERMITTED TO LEAVE THE WORK SITE
TO FIND SAFETY THEY WERE ALSO
TOLD NOT TO ACCESS THEIR PHONES
TO TRACK WEATHER CONDITIONS. IN
MY OPINION THE TEAMSTERS WE HAVE
SEEN IT HAPPEN TO WAREHOUSE AND
DISTRIBUTION CENTER WORKERS BUT
WE KNOW THAT FARM WORKERS
DOMESTIC WORKERS AND LANDSCAPING
WORKERS ARE OFTEN THE ONES THAT
ARE EXPECTED TO CONTINUE
WORKING. IN UNSAFE CONDITIONS AT
THE FEDERATION UNION EVERY
INDUSTRY WE HAVE HEARD THESE
STORIES FROM OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS ACROSS LOS ANGELES AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. CURRENT
LAW IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO KEEP
WORKERS SAFE FOR THESE REASONS
THE ALLEY COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR IS PROUD TO SPONSOR. THIS
BILL WITH THE TEAMSTERS UNION
AND THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT OF SO
MANY UNIONS AND IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS WE THANK SENATOR
MARIA LANDED ASAL PREPARING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR A DATE OF
THE ACCIDENT. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MR THE NEXT WHAT KARINA
LOPEZ IF YOU'RE THERE YOU MAY
PRESS. OKAY THANK YOU. SENATOR
FOR G. MY NAME IS KARINA LOPEZ
MY FAMILY WORK THAT'S- ON THE
WAREHOUSE LOS ANGELES. RAMS
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FORTY FOUR ALTERED BY SENATOR
MARTY AND THEN NOT TO WRESTLE.
FOR FULL TRAVEL FROM. THE HIGHLY
STRESSFUL AND COMPETITIVE
ENVIRONMENT WE'RE CONSTANTLY
PRESSURED AND IT MIGHT WORK
FASTER THAN. I THOUGHT HIGH
INJURY RATES THAT RESULT FROM
THIS HIGH SPEED AND HIGH
PRESSURE WORK ENVIRONMENT AMAZON
CONTINUES TO PRIORITIZE
PRODUCTION OVER IT ASSOCIATES.
MY WRIST WAS ACTUALLY INJURED IN
JANUARY THIS YEAR BECAUSE I WAS
PRESSURED TO SCAN PACKAGES. OF
FASTER DURING ONE STATION TO
MEET THEIR RATE- I'M STILL IN
PAIN RIGHT NOW AND I HAVE TO GO
TO PHYSICAL THERAPY- FOR AMAZON
PACKAGES ME MORE THAN WORKERS.
EVEN IN THE CASE OF AN EMERGENCY
SUCH AS WAREHOUSE FIRES OR NOT
THE DISASTERS AMAZON HAS PROVEN
THAT IT WILL NOT PUT THE SAFETY
OF ITS WORKERS OVER THEIR BOTTOM
LINE. DURING THE BOBCAT PLAYERS
IN TWENTY TWENTY MANY OF MY
COWORKERS WORKED IN A WAREHOUSE
NEAR THE SAN GABRIEL MOUNTAINS.
REFLECTED TO CONTINUE SHOWING UP
TO WORK DESPITE THE HIGHLY
UNSAFE CONDITIONS. I'M I'M
CONTINUOUSLY IGNORED WORKERS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE AIR QUALITY
IN THE WAREHOUSE WHICH IS
ESPECIALLY BAD. BECAUSE OF THE
PROXIMITY TO THE FIGHTERS. WHAT
MAKES YOU FEEL GREAT THAT IN. TO
WORK IN BEING AND CONDITION. WE
HAVE FAMILY AND COMMUNITIES THAT
DEPEND ON US. AND THEN IN A
MOMENT OF CRISIS WE NEED TO FEEL
EMPOWERED TO CHOOSE OUR SAFETY
AT WORK. AT FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR
WILL ALLOW WORKERS THE
PROTECTION TO CHOOSE THEIR
SAFETY WITHOUT RISKING THEIR
ECONOMIC LIVELIHOOD. I PRACTICE
BEFORE AND WE STAND FORTY FOUR
AND- YOUR GUESTS VOTE. FEAST
REASONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY OF BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM HERE WILL ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE PRESENT WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. HAS BECOME A FORTY.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS JANICE
SMILEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND SPORTS THANK YOU
. SECURITY BUT HE ALSO WISHING
TO COME FORWARD AND SUPPORT.
SEEN NONE WE WILL MOVE TO- THE
MODERATOR AND ASK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY QUEUED UP IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL OF SO PLEASE- BEGIN TO
CALL THEM NOW. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FORTY FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN FORTY FOUR. MANY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE SYSTEM
BREMBO CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE PROCESSING OUR SUPPORT
POSITION. NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU WILL HAVE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MERRY GO YEAH
SHE HARMED BY HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT. NINE ONE OH
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING KAREN
MEMBERS ACTING VERY WELL WITH
THE F. B. W. WESTERN CAPE TOWN
BLANK ON THE- NINE NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL
THE AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION
UNITE HERE THE MACHINISTS UNION
AND UTILITY WORK YOUR WORKERS
UNION OF AMERICA ALL IN SUPPORT
. NINE ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN BIRD
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND OMMITTEE MEMBERS
WE GOT THAT WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SHEET METAL AIR RAIL AND
TRANSPORTATION WORKERS
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION SMART TV
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MICHAEL
CONCERTS PRESIDENT OF NORTHEAST.
OF LOS ANGELES STRONG SUPPORT.
ONE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE OF WORK
FOR HER. GOOD EVENING AND HER
BERYL BEHALF WITH HELP WHEN YOUR
FOOD'S PLEASE APPROPRIATION AND
SUPPORT. BY FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALL RIGHT YOU
ARE MOANING WITH COLORFUL NURSE
ASSOCIATION ALSO SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NINE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS VICTOR EARL.
INTERNAL ORGANIZE YOU DIRECTOR
WITH TEAMSTERS LOCAL THREE
NINETY SIX AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF 50% FORTY FOUR. ONE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAN MEMBERS CAITLIN
BAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA I ASKED YOU COUNSEL
AND UNITE HERE LOCAL ELEVEN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE EIGHTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KIND OF OUR YOU KNOW ORGANIZING
DIRECTOR AT THE LA COUNTY LABOR
AND WE AREN'T TALKING POINTS.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FORTY FOUR.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU YOUR
MODERATOR OF WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NOW TO LEAD. OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO-
AND I'M GONNA CALL ON ASHLEY
HOFFMAN FIRST SERVICE OR IN THE
ROOM EARLIER. PLEASE GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
ASHLEY HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION SP TEN
FORTY FOUR AS A JOB KILLER. WE
ARE STILL REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS BEING TAKEN TODAY AND
DO SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS BY THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
IN THE SPONSOR TO TALK WITH US.
BUT I DO WANT TO RAISE SEVERAL
CONCERNS. I WANT TO START BY
SAYING SAFETY IS AND ALWAYS
SHOULD BE THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY FOR BOTH EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL
LAWS PROVIDE ROBUST PROTECTIONS
FOR WORKERS. TO NAME A FEW
WORKERS MAY REFUSE TO PERFORM
WORK IF IT WOULD VIOLATE THE LAW
OR HE WOULD EXPOSE THEM TO
SERIOUS INJURY OR WORSE- FURTHER
JUST TWO YEARS AGO THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED A BILL
EXPLICITLY SAYING THAT YOU
CANNOT FORCE. ANY WORKER
INCLUDING A DOMESTIC WORKER TO
ENTER OR TO REMAIN IN EVACUATION
AREA THEY'RE ALSO LAWS
REGULATIONS THAT REGULATE WHEN
IT IS SAFE TO WORK IN CERTAIN
CONDITIONS SUCH AS HEAT OR
SMOKE. THIS MEANS THAT LARGELY
THE EXAMPLES COVER BY THE
PROPONENTS WE DO RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE I BELIVE THOSE ARE
LARGELY COVERED BY EXISTING
LAWS. FOR EXAMPLE THE EXAMPLE
ABOUT ON THE DOMESTIC WORKER
BEING ORDERED TO REPORT DURING
THE GETTING FIRED THAT WOULD OF
COURSE BE PROHIBITED NOW UNDER
THE LAW PASSED TWO YEARS AGO- OR
IF THERE'S A WORKER YOU KNOW
WHEN THERE'S A FIRE BLAZING NEXT
DOOR ANOTHER IMMINENT DANGER WE
THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY ILLEGAL
RIGHT NOW TO MAKE THAT WORK OR
CONTINUE TO WORK. WE THINK
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE AND THE
EMPLOYER SHOULD ABSOLUTELY BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE. I'M SO OUR
CONCERN- TEN FORTY FOUR IS
LARGELY TWO FOLD- AS A COMEDIAN
HOUSES NOTES IN A STATE OF
EMERGENCY CAN LAST FOR A LONG
TIME BEYOND WHEN THE DANGER IS
PRESENT. AND WHILE WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THIS WE DO STILL HAVE
SOME CONCERNS. ABOUT THE USE OF
THE LANGUAGE OF THE EMERGENCY
BEING ONGOING WHICH WE THINK IS
VERY GOOD AND COULD COVER SOME
EMERGENCIES SUCH AS WILDFIRES
SMOKE OR OTHERS THAT DO LAST
POTENTIALLY FOR A VERY LONG
TIME. EVEN MORE CAL OSHA HAS
DENIED THAT IT IS SAFE TO GO TO
WORK. A SECOND AND PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST CONCERN WE HAVE THE BILL
IS THAT IT GIVES LARGE
DISCRETION TO EMPLOYEES THAT IF
THEY WALK AWAY FROM A COMPLETELY
SAFE WORKPLACE. THERE'S NOTHING
THERE WE ARE CAN DO. RISK A
LOSS. HEALTH CARE WORKERS FIRST
RESPONDERS YOUR OWN LEGISLATIVE
STAFF COULD WALK AWAY TODAY. IF
THIS BILL IS IN EFFECT IF THEY
SAY ANYTHING IS UNSAFE. THE FACT
THAT THE EMPLOYER IS FOLLOWING
APPROPRIATE LAWS- IS GOING EVEN
ABOVE AND BEYOND IS RELEVANT TO
THE FACT THAT CAL OSHA OR CD PH
OR WHOEVER SAYS IT IS SAFE TO
WORK. IS COMPLETELY IRRELEVANT
THE BILL TAKES THE POWER
COMPLETELY OUT OF THOSE AGENCIES
HANDS. AS FAR AS WHAT
CONSTITUTES A SAFER PLACE.
FINALLY JUST A PIECE ON
ENFORCEMENT- THE BILL IS
ENFORCEABLE UNDER PROJECT. I'M
PRESENTLY IF YOU HAVE A
VIOLATION UNDER PAGA FOR
VIOLATION OF THE HEALTH OR
SAFETY STATUTE- YOU ARE SUPPOSED
TO. FOLLOW A DIFFERENT PROCEDURE
BY WHICH WE MUST HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATED- BEFORE
YOU CAN FILE A LAWSUIT. AND
BECAUSE THIS DOES NOT PUT THIS
CODE SECTION IN THAT SAME
DIVISION AS THE REST OF THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE IT WOULD
NOT BE SUBJECT TO THAT SAME
PROCEDURE. WHICH IS ACTUALLY
WORSE FOR WORKERS BECAUSE
INSTEAD OF GETTING A CITATION
IMMEDIATELY THEY WOULD HAVE TO
WAIT MONTHS RESOLUTION OF A
LOSS. TO ADDRESS AT THE VERY
LEAST- THIS BE PUT IN THAT SAME
DIVISION AS THE OTHER HEALTH
AND- THE- YOU- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY- THE SECOND LEAD
UP SOCIAL WITNESSES JOHNNY PINA-
I BELIEVE ON THE COASTLINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE NUMBERS STARTING
WITH ME WHAT LEGAL CALIFORNIA
CITY THANK YOU OFTEN NEED TO
TESTIFY TODAY. I'M HERE IN
RESPECT OF THIS IN THE SP TEN
FORTY FOUR I'D LIKE TO PUT A
COMMENT OF THE CALCHAMBER AND
ALSO BRIEFLY ADD THE PERSPECTIVE
OF LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES. IT IS
THE GREASE THAT PLASTIC IN PLACE
TO PROTECT WORKERS AND PROVIDE
SECRET PLACES HOWEVER AT LEAST
IN EARLIER THIS BILL COULD CREEP
TELL. AMERICANS THE RESPONSE
THIS BILL APPLIES TO ALL
EMPLOYEES INCLUDING THOSE
RESPONDING DIRECTLY TO
EMERGENCIES. CURRENTLY DRAFTED
SB TEN FORTY FOUR COULD. INHIBIT
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND REDUCE WORKPLACE
SAFETY BY ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES MANY OF
WHOM COULD BE RESPONDING TO THE
EMERGENCY ENDED AFTER TAKING
PLACE TO SIMPLY NOT SHOW UP TO
WORK WITH NO RECOURSE IF THEY
FEEL UNSAFE REGARDLESS. OF THE
SAFETY. MEASURES IN PLACE. FOR
ME. IN THE CITIES. FIRST TO
DISASTER AN ALL HANDS ON DECK
APPROACH WHERE EMPLOYEES COULD
BE REASSIGNED BASED ON THE NEEDS
OF THE TIME. THIS BILL MAKES IT
DIFFICULT TO PLAN AND ORGANIZE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE WHEN
EMPLOYEES CONFUSED- ABOUT THE
JOB OR NOT SHOW UP WITH NO
EXCEPTION FOR JOB DUTY OR
CLASSIFICATION. THIS WOULD LEAVE
THE EMPLOYEES THAT DO SHOW UP
WITH MY STAFF TO PERFORM THE
DUTIES AT HAND IN. THIS
EMERGENCY TIME OUT. FINALLY IT'S
STILL OPEN LOCAL AGENCIES UP TO
LAWSUITS THAT STATED PREVIOUSLY
. SHOULD THEY SEEK TO REPLACE
WORKERS TO PROVIDE TIME
SENSITIVE. DUTIES WHICH WOULD
FURTHER LIMIT THAT DISASTER
RESPONSE. LOCAL EMERGENCY
SERVICE PERSONNEL IN ITS
POSITIONS- TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES AND MAINTAIN ORDER
AND SAFETY TO THE PUBLIC THIS
REQUIRES A- IF I RESPOND- THE
STORE UNDER MY ARM ABILITY TO
ADEQUATELY RESPOND. TO IMMEDIATE
EMERGENCIES INCLUDE ONGOING
STAFFING SHORTAGES- CAN PRODUCE
EMISSIONS WITHIN THE BILL I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR AND THE STAFF FOR
THEIR- WILLINGNESS TO. HE NEEDS
TO WORK ON I DISPEL. HOWEVER THE
REASON STATED AFTER I RESPECT
THAT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
WENT ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION- PLEASE COME ON
FORWARD. THANK YOU. EVERY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
WOULD YOU SAY YOUR NAME NAME
OVER AGAIN FOR THE RECORD AARON
AVERY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
WAS ON THE RECORDING THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FOR A LITTLE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS ARTICULATED BY MISS
HOFFMAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
ANYONE ELSE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. SCENE DON'T COME FORWARD
WE'LL GO BACK TO THE MODERATOR.
OF AND REPEAT THE PROCESS WE
TOOK EARLIER ASKING IF THERE'S
ANYONE. UP IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL QUEUED UP ON THE LINE. THEN
LATER ON IF YOU ARE AN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION. INSURE THIS TIME WE
DO HAVE SIX IN OUR QUEUE. THANK
YOU PLEASE PROCEED. WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER ONE OH THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
NUMBERS HE HAS BEEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION RESPECT BELIEVE
OPPOSE SB TEN FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
SIXTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON RAIN
THROUGH THE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANKS TO BE NINETY NINE. THE
AFTERNOON GILLIAN BROWN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WITH SUPPORT POSITION. WHEN I
CALLED THE NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT.
MY NAME IS ROBERT PATRICK ON THE
PRESIDENCY OF THE LODI DISTRICT
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ON BEHALF OF
ITS BOARD OF DIRECTORS IS
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS COMMITTEE
AND ALMOST NINE HUNDRED MEMBERS
WE STAND OPPOSED TO THIS
LEGISLATION. THANKS TO THE
NUMBER FORTY. HEY WONDERING WHAT
THE VALLEY INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION LIKE THAT IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION S. B. ONE
OH FOUR FOUR. NOW THE NUMBER
NINETEEN. NUMBER NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DAVE BUTLER ON BEHALF
OF THE UNITED CHAMBER ADVOCACY
NETWORK A COALITION OF US SEVEN
LOCAL CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE HERE
NOR THE CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
OVER SEVEN THOUSAND EMPLOYERS IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. NEXT IS
NUMBER FIFTY FOUR. EVERYTHING
WOULD BE A FIFTY CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT. YEAH. NOW
GO TO NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS MICHAEL BELL
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE SUPPORT THE INTENT
OF THE BILL BUT RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SURE THE TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. WE'RE GONNA COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE AND- FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS- THIRD
ROWS OF JUST. THE FACT THAT-
IT'S PRETTY PRESENTATION TICKET
THAT YOU. HAVE ACCEPTED THE
COMMITTEE. AMENDMENTS AND THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH BIG STUFF
SO CLOSELY- TO MAKE THOSE
MODIFICATIONS- EIGHT I DON'T I
WOULD SUPPOSE BUT IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO I JUST WANT TO GIVE
YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND TO
THE IS THE ONE QUESTION I HAVE
WITH REGARD TO- I THINK WHAT
PEOPLE BEEN REFERRING TO IS THE
ENDING DATE AND I KNOW. THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- DEAL WITH
THAT- CERTAINLY FOR TODAY AS YOU
MENTIONED IN YOUR PRESENTATION
THE INTENT WAS NOT TO CREATE-
THE FEDERATION THAT WOULD EXTEND
TO THE FULL PERIOD OF A STATE OF
EMERGENCY WHICH WE ALL KNOW- CAN
TAKE SOME TIME. AND- YEAH I
THINK WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
OPPOSITION IS OR WHAT
INTERESTING CONTENT TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THAT. BUT LANGUAGE
FURTHER AND I JUST WANT TO KNOW
WHAT YOUR RESPONSE OF ANYTHING
WAS TO THAT. IN IN TERMS OF
VALUE WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THEM. YES I AM I
MEAN. I WILL I HAVE EVERY
INTENTION TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THEM. WITH THESE ON THESE
ISSUES AND AS LONG AS THE- BASIC
INTENT AND PURPOSE OF THE- OF
THE- OF THE BILL IS. PRESERVED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
TUNE IN AGAIN APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH WORKING WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF TO TRY TO GET WHAT I THINK
IS PRETTY PRETTY GOOD LANGUAGE-
BEFORE US TODAY OTHERMEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- SIR NEWMAN AND
THANK YOU MISTRESS SHOW FOR-
YEAH I DO TOO- GETTING WELL
FIRST OF ALL THIS THIS IS ONE OF
THESE BILLS THIS IS. TOO LITTLE
BILL BIG DEAL RIGHT AT THE
MOMENT SO IF THIS IS THE ISSUE
THAT I THINK THE SHORTEST- BILL
THAT WE HAVE WITH US- AND YET
THIS IS CLEARLY A MAJOR.
UNDERTAKING SHOW I DO I WANT TO
I WANT TO JUST TOUCH ON- MS
HOFFMAN'S POINT OF VIEW ABOUT
THIS TENSION OF THE JURY DO THIS
TENSION BETWEEN. OUR TWO CATS
TAKE EMERGENCY DECLARATIONS
WHICH ARE INTENTIONALLY BROAD-
AND USING CODE EXAMPLE INTEND TO
EXTEND WELL BEYOND THAT PERIOD
WITH A DANGEROUS PLACEMOST
FRAUD- AND THEN TAKE CARE OF THE
CAL OSHA- PIECE WHERE YOU KNOW
WE START TO GET MORE
DEFINITIONAL. AND THERE'S A
TENSION THERE- AND SO IS THAT
YOUR INDICATED I THINK YOU'RE
WILLING TO RENDER SOME CLARITY
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD AND NOT
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
CORRECT. YES THERE IS NO PROBLEM
AND GET WE WANT CLARITY THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO GIVE
CLARITY. UNDER CONDITIONS OF
EMERGENCY WHERE YOU DIDN'T KNOW.
HOW COULD YOU EXPECT THAT THERE
WOULD BE A MASS SHOOTING AT THE
SCHOOL FOR YOUR CHILDREN ARE ARE
GOING TO SCHOOL HOW WOULD YOU
KNOW THAT YOU CAN PROVIDE FOR
THAT YOU KNOW IN IN THE PLAN- IN
IN THE SAME WAY SO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THINGS THAT ARE OUT OF OUR
CONTROL THAT HAPPENED SUDDENLY
WHAT DO YOU DO IN THAT REAL
MOMENT IN TIME. FOR THINGS THAT
YOU CANNOT- YOU KNOW EVEREVEN
EXPECT WHAT HAPPENED IN THE WAY
THAT THEY WOULD HAPPEN EVEN
UNDER THE QUICK WHAT DID YOU SAY
HOW WOULD THAT IMPACT. YOUR
PARTICULAR WORKPLACE OR- YOUR
FAMILY. WHERE YOU'RE FROM IS
LIVING. YOU ASK YOURSELF WHAT
WOULD WE WANT DO IN CASE OF AN
EARTHQUAKE. THAT HITS YOU KNOW
WHERE YOUR FAMILY WHERE YOUR
HOME IS. YOU WANNA LEAVE. YOU
WANNA LEAVE AND YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO LEAVE BECAUSE YOUR
FAMILY. THERE'S A POTENTIAL OF A
LIFE AND DEATH SITUATION SO.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO
CLARIFY BECAUSE OF THE RULES AS
THEY ARE TODAY THE LAWS AS THEY
ARE TODAY. DO NOT COVER THESE
ALL POINT IN REAL TIME
SITUATIONS. NO AND I APPRECIATE
THAT BUT THERE'S BEEN SOME. SORT
OF RESPECT THIS GAME AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT- THERE'S ALREADY
A LAW IN PLACE- THAT COVERS SUN
AT LEAST SOME OF THESE
DIMENSIONS AND SO I I'M I'M
ASSUMING THAT AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD TO WORK WITH. OPPOSITION
WITH THE CONSULTANTS- TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE YOU KOW WE GET
CLARITY. ABSOLUTELY YOU SHOULD
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR THANKS
SIR. RESELLER NEWMAN- INSULAR
ARM. THE SENATOR NEWMAN DID A
BUNCH OF WHAT I WANT TO DO
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS ON TWO
LEVELS I THINK THE ACTUAL
SITUATIONS THE THINGS THAT NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED THE QUESTION IS
HOW TO MAKE SURE THE BILL
ACTUALLY DOES THAT. IN THE RIGHT
. A. N. IT'S BEEN MY MISFORTUNE
BUT TO BE AN ELECTED OFFICIAL IN
THE MIDDLE OF SOME OF THE SIR
DEREK- I HAD BEEN ON THE CITY
COUNCIL FOR. SIX WEEKS WHEN WE
HAD THE HUNDRED YEAR STORM. AND
IT TRUST. THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED SUDDENLY THE RIVER IS A
FOOT FROM FLOOD STAGE AND
FLOODING THE WHOLE DOWNTOWN
SEVENTY FIVE FOOT REDWOOD TREES
BATTERED DOWN THE BRIDGE R. A.
AND I'M AT WORK IN THE
COURTHOUSE LOOKING DOWN AT THIS
WHEN PEOPLE ARE GETTING CALLS
AND SAYING GET UP TO THE
MOUNTAINS YOU'RE ONLY HAVE A FEW
MINUTES BEFORE YOU CAN GET THERE
SAFELY AND WE'RE GONNA BE
MAROONED FOR AWHILE AND SO N.
THEN I HAD THE MISFORTUNE. TO
HAVE THAT SAME DOWNTOWN
DESTROYED BY AN EARTHQUAKE A FEW
YEARS LATER 60% OF THE SQUARE
FOOTAGE IN THE DOWNTOWN WAS
DESTROYED AND THERE WERE THESE
HORRIFIC SITUATIONS OF A
GENERATOR GOING IN THE NIGHT.
AFTER THE QUAKE WOULD HAVE
CAUSED. THE EARTH. THE WALLS TO
SHAKE OF UNREINFORCED BRICK
WHERE THEY WERE DIGGING FOR
PEOPLE AND THEY HAD REAL TOUGH
LIFE AND DEATH DECISIONS TO
MAKE. ABOUT WHETHER TO CONTINUE
THOSE SEARCH AND RESCUES IN THE
DARK WHEN THOSE WERE THE ONLY
CONDITIONS AND SO. I SUBSCRIBE
TO BOTH PARTS THERE ARE THESE
SITUATIONS END. NOBODY SHOULD BE
PUNISHED FOR PROTECTING
THEMSELVES IN THE SITUATION AT
THE SAME TIME YOU HAVE TO WRITE
THE BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
REALLY APPLIES TO THEM SO. OUR
OUR OUR WORLD- YOU KNOW HAPPILY
MOVE THIS ALONG AND ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT BECAUSE
IT'S CLEAR THERE IS AN ISSUE
HERE. BUT THEN YOU LOOK AT HOW
IT APPLIES IN A WAY THAT MAKES
IT MORE SO AND I APPRECIATE THE-
THE AUTHORS ARE CONSTANT
WILLINGNESS TO TAFT. TACKLED
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS IN THE
PROTECTION OF PEOPLE THAT IS ONE
OF THESE INCIDENTS. OKAY ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OF YOUR
LEADERSHIP CENTER DRAWS SO AND-
ALWAYS AN ADVOCATE FOR WAR FOR
SAFETY TO PUT IT MILDLY SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND YOU WANT TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE THIS
TIME. WELL I JUST- I KNOW THAT
MANY OF THESE WORK PLACES THAT
FIND THEMSELVES COULD FIND
THEMSELVES. YOU KNOW GOD WILLING
THEY DON'T BUT IF THEY FIND
THEMSELVES ARE YOU KNOW THE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND- THEY'RE
THE ONES IN SOME WAYS THAT NEED
THE MOST PROTECTION. I FIND THAT
OUR HUMAN INSTINCT IS NOT TO RUN
AWAY FROM SOMETHING THIS TO RUN
TOWARDS AND HELP OTHER. OTHER
PEOPLE FIVE IT'S NOT LIKE WE'RE
CHANGING PEOPLE'S. MENTALITY
THEY'RE NOT JUST LOOKING FOR AN
EXCUSE TO RUN AWAY FROM FROM AN
EMERGENCY. BUT THEY DO HAVE TO
OF COURSE WATCH OUT FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILY SO.
I APPRECIATE THE- THE QUESTIONS
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
HARD- ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- WILL MOVE TO
THE CONSULTANT- AS FOR ROLL CALL
VOTE ON SENATOR BYRD'S MOTION AT
THIS TIME. SENATOR THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PROTESTING HI
COURTESY I- TROUBLE THE TROUBLE
NO THE RUSSELL I. WRESTLE I
LAYERED. THEY'RE FINE NEWMAN
NEWMAN I. FOUR ONE ALL RIGHT THE
BILLS OUT ON FOUR TO ONE VOTE
THANK YOU AGAIN SIR DRAWS SO
AND- YOUR THIRD AND FINAL
PRESENTATION TODAY WILL BE S. B.
TEN FIFTY EIGHT. DISABILITY
INSURANCE BILL IF YOU'RE
PREPARED TO MAKE PRESENT ON THAT
BILL. I THINK THIS ONE'S A LOT
SIMPLER- MR KERR THANK YOU AND
MEMBERS- S. B. TEN FIFTY EIGHT
SIMPLY REQUIRES OF THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT- TO COLLECT DATA
REGARDING THE RACE AND ETHNICITY
OF INDIVIDUALS WILL PLY FOR
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE ON
THE PAID FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM SO
YOU COULD SEE THE CONNECTION
WITH OUR PREVIOUS BILL. IT ALSO
REQUIRES THAT THIS DATA IS
TRACKED AND REPORTED ON IN ORDER
TO INFORM ONGOING OUTREACH
EFFORTS. EDT ALREADY COLLECTS
DATA. ON THE RACE AND ETHNICITY
OF APPLICANTS FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BUT NOT FOR- STATE
DISABILITY PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
GIVEN WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED FROM-
PRIOR OUTSIDE RESEARCH RACIAL
DISPARITIES STILL EXIST WITH
RESPECT TO AWARENESS. AND UPTAKE
OF STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE
AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE. THE EDT
MUST BEGIN TO COLLECT THIS DATA
IN ORDER TO SUCCESSFULLY ASSESS
AND ADDRESS THE DISPARITIES MY
WITNESSES TODAY OUR CELEBS
STEIGER LEGAL AID AT WORK AND
ANDREA RIVERA CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK THANK YOU
MR. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- WE WILL
CALL ON THE FIRST. WITH SUPPORT
WITNESS ON THE BILL IN THAT
WOULD BE THE UNDERSTAND IT THE
SERVICE DIRECTOR IS THAT RIGHT.
YES ON THE COASTLINE IF YOU'RE
ON THE LINE YOU MAY PROCEED. TO
BE MISSED STEIGER STEIGER FOR
STRIKER I'M SORRY. AND POSSIBLY
A PROBLEM WITH THAT LINE OR-
MUTED ON THE ONLINE. WHAT WE DO
THIS- WELL WE ARE WAITING FOR
THAT TO CLEAR UP WE WILL MOVE TO
THE OTHER LEAD SPORT WITNESS-
ANDREA RIVERA ARE YOU THERE. BUT
AFTERNOON SHARING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS ANDREA
RIVERA REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA FRIENDS. OPEN AT
FIRST WOULD BE KIND. THE
STATEWIDE MULTICULTURAL ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVANCES
HEALTH EQUITY FOR BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THAT
IN ORDER TO TRULY ADVANCE HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND REDUCE DISPARITIES
AND ALL OF OUR SAFETY NET
PROGRAM. WE MUST PRIORITIZE
POLICIES THAT SEEK TO IDENTIFY
AND THEN TARGET CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE MOST IN NEED. COMPLETE
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IS THE FIRST
STEP IN ACKNOWLEDGING AND THEN
REDUCING RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DISPARITIES. OVER NINETEEN KINDA
BANK HAS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT CALIFORNIANS ARGUABLY
THE COMMUNITIES WITH THE MOST
NEED. WHILE THERE HAVE BEEN
EFFORTS IN THE PAST YOU
INCREASED WAGE REPLACEMENT
EXTEND PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND
PROVIDE JOB PROTECTED LEAVE. ACT
BEHIND THE VAT IS EXTREMELY
FOCUSED ON ACCOMPLISHING ONE
CRITICAL ASPECT THAT REMAINS
MISSING FROM THE ENTIRE PROCESS.
WHICH IS DATA COLLECTION BY
REPRESSED BY REQUIRING THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT TO COLLECT
INFORMATION ON RACE AND
ETHNICITY I THINK HER THIRTY
EIGHT PUBLISHES THE FOUNDATION
TO ADDRESS DEEPLY EMBEDDED
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS. AFTER THE
LOOTED SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES FROM
CLEANING ESSENTIAL SUPPORT FOR
FAR TOO LONG. IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN A RESEARCH STUDY BY
ANDREW CHANG COMPANY WITH
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM THE EDT WAS
PUBLISHED AND THE REPORT FOUND
WIDESPREAD EQUITIES WITH PAID
FAMILY LEAVE. FOR EXAMPLE AFTER
IN THE DOCTORS GET FAMILY LEAVE
REQUESTS ARE EXTREMELY UNDER
UTILIZED ALL CALIFORNIANS BUT
ESPECIALLY. LGBTQ COMMUNITY. IF
YOU COMMUNITIES ARE THAT WITH.
OR TO TACKED AT THE END OVER. A
FRENCH LACK CULTURAL COMPETENCY
AND FINALLY LATIN EXTREMITIES
REPORTED VERY LOW GENERAL
AWARENESS THAT THE FAMILY LEAVE
. AND- THAT DID YOU HEAR ABOUT
LEAVE PROGRAM WHERE TYPICALLY
BIOLOGICAL MOTHERS AND THEY WERE
INFORMED WHEN THEY WERE IN THE
HOSPITAL. AT THREE TEN FIFTY
EIGHT WOULD SEEK OUT A SIMPLE
QUESTION TO THE ALREADY EXISTING
APPLICATION PROCESS THE PASSAGE
OF THIS BILL THE CENTRAL TO
AFFECTING AND INCREASING USE OF
EDB PROGRAM ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE I WILL ON THE
FILM THANK. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU-
VERY MUCH AND WE'LL GO BACK TO
SETTLE THIS TIGER HE IS THERE
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU YES
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN- YOU
KNOW THANK YOU. MY APOLOGIES AND
BELIEVING AFTER TEARING MEMBER.
I AM TAYLOR THANK YOUR STAFF
ATTORNEY AT LEGAL AID AT WORK A
PROUD SPONSOR OF SB TEN FIFTY
EIGHT. LEGAL AID AT WORK IN THE
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES FOR
THE EMPLOYMENT RATE. OF LOW
INCOME WORKERS AND WORKING
FAMILIES. I'M HONORED TO BE HERE
TODAY TO SUPPORT AT THE TEN
FIFTY EIGHT AND WANT TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO THANK
SENATOR DROPPED THOUGH. FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. I THINK TEN FIFTY EIGHT
WILL REQUIRE THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT TO
COLLECT OFFICIAL RACE AND
ETHNICITY DATA FROM STATE
DISABILITY INSURANCE AND PAID
FAMILY LEAVE CLAIMANTS. ACCESS
TO PAID FAMILY LEAVE AND MEDICAL
LEAVE. THE DEFENSE OF OUR
WORKERS FAMILY. MEMBERS ARE YOU
SO THE FAMILY LEAVE CONFIRMED
THAT THE GOVERNMENT WILL HELP
OUT FROM. RIFLES AND CAREGIVERS.
INFANT HEALTH AND WELFARE OF
BONDING THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH MARKET. OUT OF THE
WORKFORCE MOST LIKELY. ALL
ACADEMIC. ALL YOU HAVE RIGHT IN
THIS AREA. WHAT LONGSTANDING.
INSURANCE PROGRAM AND LANDMARK
PASTOR OCCASION LEAVE AND
THOUSAND. YEAH YOU'RE YEAH WE
ARE WHERE PRIMARY. THAT NOT ALL.
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS THESE VITAL
PROGRAMS. CERTAIN RACIAL
DISPARITIES EXIST WITH RESPECT
TO HAVE THE WEIRDNESS OF STI AND
P. ABOUT AND HE WAS ABLE TO
ACCESS WEEK REPLACEMENT
BENEFITS. IN A RECENT STUDY OF
NEW MOTHERS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
EXAMPLE. RESEARCHERS FOUND THAT
47% OF BLACK WOMEN AND 36% OF
HISPANIC WOMEN. RECEIVE NO PAY
AT ALL FROM THE GOVERNMENT WHILE
TAKING LEAVE COMPARED. TO JUST
19% OF WHITE WOMEN. WE NEED THE
IMPLANT DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT
TO COLLECT SPECIAL RATE VANITY
DATA. AND STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE
CLAIMANT. DATA WILL PROVIDE
STAKEHOLDERS WITH CLEAR AND
MEASURABLE INFORMATION ABOUT
KNOWN RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH REFORM TARGETED OUTREACH
AND UPTAKE EFFORT AMONG
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING LEFT BEHIND. CONSIDERING
WORKERS OF ALL RACIAL
BACKGROUNDS PAY INTO THE FUND.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT THE EDT
COLLECT RACE AND ETHNICITY DATA
TO MAKE SURE. THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE ABLE TO BENEFIT
FROM THE PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY
YOU TO EXISTING LAW COLLECTION
OF FREE FITNESS THE DATA WERE
REQUIRED TO EAT LIKE VOLUNTARY
SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND GENDER-IDENTITY INFORMATION AS WELL.
PROVIDING IMPORTANT DATA ABOUT
ACCESS AND UPTAKE. AMONG LGBTQ
PLUS PAYMENT AND PREVENTING
SIMILAR OPPORTUNITIES TO ADDRESS
DISPARITIES. YOU'RE TARGETED
OUTREACH. TODAY WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION TO ENSURE EQUITABLE
ACCESS. IF THE INSURANCE IS
PAID. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY OF IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN COMMITTEE ROOM
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL- SEE NO ONE COME
FORWARD WILL GO THE MODERATOR.
ASKED MODERATOR- WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL- IF THERE
IS SO PLEASE. CALL ON THEM AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN FIFTY EIGHT IN A PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB. ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
POINT SEVENTY TWO. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARICO
YOSHIHARU ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREATENING MEMBERS AND DROP OFF
THE VEHICLE I THINK EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES WORK. ONE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KATIE WATER SMITH CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY COALITION AND PUBLIC
COUNCIL BOTH IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU
. NINE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE SAID
YES BUT THE CALIFORNIA RECALL.
FOR NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN FIFTY EIGHT
THANK YOU MODERATOR IN THERE SO
THAT NO LEAD OPPOSITION LISTED
ON THIS BILL- SO WE'LL ASK IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION THE
COMMITTEE ROOM SEE NO ONE STEP
FORWARD MODERATOR IF WE CAN COME
BACK TO YOU AND ASK YOU TO
IDENTIFY ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TEN FIFTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB TEN
FIFTY EIGHT. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN THERE. WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION OF
KENTUCKY THANK YOU MODERATOR- WE
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY COMMENTS ON THE
COMMITTEE WE HAVE FOUR QUESTIONS
- YES BUT YOU'RE- I DO HAVE-
JUST A COUPLE OF COMMENTS- AND
CONCERNS- SO THANK YOU CHAIR FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY AND MEMBERS. I
HAVE THIS THURSDAY WITH- SP TEN
FIFTY EIGHT AND I DO APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS IN ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE GOOD DATA THAT
PROVIDES MORE IN DEPTH INSIGHTS
INTO HOW THE STATE DISABILITY
INSURANCE AND PAID FAMILY WAS
BEING UTILIZED HOWEVER. I AM
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL WILL
ADD YET ANOTHER RESPONSIBILITY
TD AT A TIME WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ADDED A PLETHORA
OF NEW REQUIREMENTS- TO THEIR
PLATE. IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE
EDT PRIORITIZED RESPONDING TO AN
IMPROVING THEIR OPERATIONAL
DEFICIENCIES DEFICIENCIES SO
THAT THEY CAN TRULY SERVE THE
SAFETY NET AND SOTHAT WE DO NOT
SEE A REPEAT OF THE PANDEMIC
RESPONSE WHICH- COULD HAVE BEEN
AVOIDED- AS SOMEONE WHO HAS-
EXPRESSED CONCERNS WITH-
CURRENTLY THE EDT SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE. IN PLACE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ACCORDING TO
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST- REPORTS
WHERE THEY- EXPRESSED SOME OTHER
PRIORITY CONCERNS THAT NEEDED TO
ADDRESS TWO EDT WHICH WE HAVE
YET TO COMPLETELY- IMPLEMENTED.
I FEEL WE SHOULD PROBABLY DIRECT
OUR EFFORTS OUR TIME AND OUR
RESOURCES IN TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH WHAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
IDENTIFIED WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AS- TOP
PRIORITIES IN ORDER FOR US TO
BECOME MORE EFFECTIVE. AND MORE
EFFICIENT IN THE PROCESSES EDP
SO I WHILE I DO BELIEVE THAT
THIS HAS MERIT I THINK WE DO
HAVE OTHER PRIORITIES THAT WE DO
HAVE TO. ADDRESS FIRST BEFORE WE
ADD YET ANOTHER REQUIREMENT TO
EDT- IT IS FOR THAT REASON THAT
AT THIS TIME I WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THIS BUT I AM A HUGE
PROPONENT. OF TRYING TO GATHER
DATA IN ORDER TO BEST ABOUT YOU-
BEST. BASICALLY HAVE BEST
PRACTICES IN PLACE FOR DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS IN GOVERNMENT. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MA'AM BYE SURE
ANYONE ELSE WISHING COMMONER AS
QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL THE C.
NINE SENATOR ALSO YES SIR. YEAH
ALL RIGHT SIR KNEW WAS GONNA
MOVE THE BILL- HE ANSWERED ROSAL
BEFORE WE TAKE IT UP. IN FINAL
TERMS HERE- YOU DO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE IF YOU WISH.
TO JUST TO. QUICKLY RESPOND TO-
MY COLLEAGUE- THE ANALYSTS L.
ALES RECOMMENDATIONS WERE WITH
REGARD TO THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. IT WOULD NOT WITH
REGARDS TO STI ON THE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE- THIS IS A VERY
SIMPLE CHECK THE BOX. IT'S NOT
SOMETHING OVERWHELMING OR ARE
ARE SO MATERIALLY SIGNIFICANT-
SO I WOULD JUST I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR ALBERT THANK YOU. READ
SENATOR THANK YOU AGAIN- WE WILL
COME BACK TO THE CONSULTANT THIS
TIME AND- ASK FOR A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON SENATOR NEWMAN'S MOTION
IN THIS CASE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COURTESY. COURTESY I OR TROUBLE
NO THE TROUBLE NO THE RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I LAYERED HI LARRY I
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN HI- IT
IS BEATEN FIFTY IT IS AWFUL FOUR
TO ONE VOTE THANK YOU. AGAIN I
AM GOING TO PASS THE GAVEL ONE
MORE TIME TO- TO OUR VOICE YOUR
VOICE YOUR OTRO BOAT IN ASKER. A
TO CONDUCT THE PROCEEDINGS- SO
THAT I MAY PRESENT AS B. TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT- IN CONFORMANCE
WITH THE RULES. HER THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE- SO. WOULD YOU BE AT
PLEASE PROCEED WITH PRESENTING
YOUR BILL SB TWELVE SEVENTY
EIGHT YES THANK YOU MATT MILLEN
VICE CHAIR AND A MEMBER SO I
APPRECIATE YOU ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT SP TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT
TWO U. S. B. TWELVE SEVENTY IS A
VERY SIMPLE BILLING TO PROVIDE
US WITH IMPORTANT INFORMATION
REGARDING WORKPLACE INJURIES AND
OCCUPATIONAL DISEASES AND
PATHOLOGIES EXISTING LAW DOES
REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO FIRST PLACE
OF EMPLOYMENT THAT IS SAFE FOR
ALL WORKERS. WHEN THERE'S AN
INJURY ILLNESS OR DEATH WHICH
OCCURS ON THE JUMPERS ARE
REQUIRED TO REPORT TO THE
DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH BETTER KNOWN AS OSHA
CAL OSHA'S AND REQUIRED TO
COMPILE THIS INFORMATION AND
MAKE IT AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
UNFORTUNATELY THE DATA ITSELF IS
NOT READILY ACCESSIBLE THE BILL
SIMPLY DIRECTS THE ARTIST'S
MENAND REPORT WORKPLACE INJURIES
AND OCCUPATIONAL DISEASES
DISEASES AND PATHOLOGIES TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
THAT IS PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE.
THIS INFORMATION IS NECESSARY
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS BUT
PRIMARILY HELP GUIDE POLICY AND
FOCUS ON THE AREAS OF
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
AT THE IMPROVEMENTS OR REFORMS
PROTECTING IMPROVIN THE WORKING
CONDITIONS OF WORKERS AS WE'VE
HEARD HERE TODAY IS OUR PRIORITY
AND GETTING ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION IS CRUCIAL TO THE
PUBLIC PARTICULARLY IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO CHEATING THIS
GOAL RESPECTFULLY- ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. I DO NOT HAVE LEAD
WITNESSES TODAY- AND I'LL TURN
IT BACK TO THE BY SURE THIS TIME
PERFECT THAK YOU S.
INTERPRETATION WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ANYONE WANTED TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT- DO WE HAVE ANY- WILL
BEGIN WITH WITNESSES. HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED DO WE
HAVE ANY. NOPE NOT HERE. THANK
YOU A NUMBER TO WITNESS WAITING
TO TESTIFY THE TELECONFERENCE OR
VERSUS. MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WHEN
SHE TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THE FALL
SEVENTY EIGHT. S. ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. BUT AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO CHECK JUST ONE MORE TIME
THE LINES MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
NOT MISSING ANYONE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE SEVENTY
EIGHT IN THE QUEUE. PERFECT WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO- ARE. WELL
ACTUALLY WE DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION- SO WE WOULD GO ON TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY- PRESS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED AND I SEE NO ONE. THE
FACT THAT A MODERATE IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT THERE'S ONE
IN THE THIRD ROW AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF FC OF
SEVENTY EIGHT THE FIRST ONE AND
THEN CLEARING. WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO FIFTY
TWELVE FIFTY. THANK YOU- MADAME
MODERATOR- THANK YOU TO SURE WE
DON'T HAVE ANYONE TO THINK TODAY
I WILL NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO THE MEMBERS DO WE HAVE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FIRE-
FIRE MEMBERS AND I BELIEVE
SENATOR HUMAN. SERVICES HAND
THANK YOU FOR SURE BUT I WANT TO
WEIGH IN IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND ALL KIDDING ASIDE IT WAS
REALLY MATURE THAT THERE WAS NO
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL TO TAKE
THIS THIS IS ONE OF MANY
EXAMPLES WHERE THERE IS DATA
AVAILABLE CALIFORNIA WHERE WE
SHOULD COLLECT DATA AND USE THAT
DATA TO MAKE SMARTER DECISIONS
MANAGE PROGRAM SO GLAD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL GLAD TO MOVE
IT ALSO LOOKING FORWARD TO.
HAVING DINNER THIS EVENING THANK
YOU. SENATOR LAYERED I WAS GOING
TO MOVE OKAY. IT WORKS OR NOT SO
GOOD FOR. SO WE HAVE A MOTION TO
REMOVE THE VEIL OUT BY SENATOR
LARRY- AND SENATOR CORTESE DO
WHICH WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE YES
SIR THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN FOR
BECOMING THE FIRST. PERSON
PERSON NOT CENTER PERSON IN
HISTORY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND I WANNA THINK CENTER WERE
FOR THE MOTION AND- ALL JOKING
ASIDE I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. PO. THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASS BUT FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
FIRST REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS COURTESY.
COURTESY I OR TROUBLE I WOULD
SHOW A BOOK I WRESTLE. THE REST
I LAYERED ALL RIGHT LORD I
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN I. SO I
HAVE AND THIS BILL IS OUT WITH
FIVE EISEN'S ERA KNOWS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YEAH PASS IT ON TO
SENATOR FOR TENNESSEE. THANK YOU
MADAM VICE YOU'RE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR- ORDERLY
DISPOSITION OF- A COUPLE OF OUR
BILLS- THIS AFTERNOON I'M GOING
TO THINK THE STAFF FOR A GREAT
JOB AS USUAL AND- WITH THAT.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW AT YOUR END.
WELL DONE. INSPECTION FOR
EVERYBODY OKAY WELL.